this episode brought to you by great
block pizza and also bronx-born pizza
and gray block pizzas in Los Angeles on
Pico Boulevard in Santa Monica and
bronx-born pizza excuse me I got some
nutmeg or something I throat and
bronx-born pizza is in Bend Oregon so if
you're in California or Oregon you're
gonna stop in to a place and get a
beautiful slice of a beautiful pizza
thank you
gray block today's guest is fresh off of
the Bruce Willis roast she's a comedian
she is she's a sweet she's a sweet woman
and it is miss Nikki Glaser
[Music]
the sticky who do people have to tell
you that really yeah
[Music]
no I waiting call you over that I mean
stick Nicky is good
yeah sticky Nicky has I can't believe
it's not a porn stars name
I have like a porn stars name Glaser
Nikki Glaser I'd Glaser like yeah the
first time that I ever felt attractive
to a guy like I grew up being just like
very awkward and being like no boy will
ever like me or see me as someone that
they were really date I could see is
that the [ __ ] that long breadstick
I'd [ __ ] want to get edit fade out ya
wanna carve up on that first day come
out you don't think that people would
want to well in high school I don't know
what you were like but I was just not
cute
I just didn't figure it out until like
junior year and then I overheard a guy
pointing at my picture in the yearbook
and being like I'd like to glaze that
and I was like oh my god a guy wants to
jizz on me like it felt I felt so
beautiful yeah that was the first time I
was like am i attractive to men oh
that's cool
yes and that in some of that's natural I
think anytime you hear somebody like
yeah if you hear somebody they say they
want to you know spray out on yeah I
guess it does fire you up as a child you
know it was just finally I mean it was
yeah I was I just was waiting for that
moment it was happening to all my
friends and I was like when is someone
gonna notice me and and it was just that
kind of like taking my glasses off and
letting my hair down and they're like
you're beautiful I was and then it took
me many many years before I let like any
guy I didn't like kiss someone until I
was my junior year was my first kiss and
then after that it was like years before
I had another kiss real in and I didn't
have sex until I was 21 and then it was
years until I started like having actual
you know you you lose your virginity but
that doesn't mean you're just like
banging left and right oh yeah get it
over with
oh yeah I lost my virginity on a bowling
alley dude which is crazy yeah behind a
bowling alley
yeah that's such a people are throwing
rocks at us there was his kids it was
just one kid definitely and something
was wrong with him
nothing's wrong with him by our standard
something's not you know God didn't put
him down here at a hundred percent you
know I'm saying if you will and uh him
in some other category it might have
been rocks I met him in shale stone but
it was still hard not hard to [ __ ] when
people are throwing rocks it's like the
Middle East you know like the Gaza Strip
oh my god okay so were you in a car were
you outside outside outdoors and so
you're standing yeah up against like a
truck or something at a building a
building we're having rocks thrown out
you I don't this is a bowling alley so
we don't like it how did this like
happen how did we were in love we were
in love oh you it was your girlfriend oh
yeah okay why do it there you know I
just think it you know we were uh you
know we could do it there we were young
you can stand and [ __ ] easier when
you're young yeah remember those days
I mean no I think I like started having
sex when everyone was done standing and
[ __ ] oh wow you're like all - it's
not fun trying to [ __ ] a tall girl
really honest oh no really I mean here's
the thing I come in I'm that [ __ ]
polish bad boy I roll in at six feet you
know I'm that Polus Nicaraguan just
something that [ __ ] you know I'm rolling
it that you know just that basic height
and so and and it's hard it's definitely
you got it really you have to have a
little bit more of a plan you got to
really want to [ __ ] to [ __ ] a tall girl
yeah I am I've never had any complaints
but I date a lot of short guys - like
I'll take guys that are shorter than me
I just mean like you just need to be
strong you can be short and be like
strong and I could still get thrown
around and stuff but yet having sex
standing up I don't do it as much and
it's probably cuz I'm a tall lady yeah
yeah it's just a bummer I feel like
because it seems like you know it's it's
like a fun thing to do I remember when I
was young it seemed like pretty fun you
know yeah and then but I but for taller
girls it's like you know I feel like you
had to like if you see if you were to
have sex in the kitchen or something and
you wanted to get behind your lady you
had to like for a tall girl you had to
like almost you know open the fridge and
like
you know put a foot on that crisper
drawer or something or you had to plan
ahead yeah I do have to do some angling
anytime I have I mean it's all about
angles and like what's the right like
some people I am not one of these girls
that's like I love being on top like I
just being on top for me as first of all
it's it's really a lot of work like it's
like it hurts your legs a lot and um and
it just doesn't it doesn't do whatever
like I need it to do to like have the
best time down there
yeah the angle isn't my favorite but
some girls are like I can only do it on
top and I feel like they're watching me
too much like I kind of like to be able
to be well I just yeah the girl on top I
mean I'm always a girl on bottom you are
I want to just relax like I want to
accept the sex and just like hat like I
don't just lay there I'm not just like
that but like I like to be I like to be
the victim yes yeah yeah yeah and I mean
I guess that word is not great to use
but I kind of like what you're saying
because I like to be pursued and like
like I just want to feel I think every
woman not every woman but I know me and
a lot of women we just want to feel so
desired like I had a hook-up recently
where I was like this guy doesn't care
enough but he's not psyched enough for
this to be happening and he should be so
psyched because I looked so hot that
night I'm like why you you you don't
deserve this I got really mad at what
were you wearing what were you wearing
I was wearing like it was the night of
the roast of Bruce Willis why doesn't
look too the hottest I'll ever look I
was peeking oh wait I saw some images
and you had like a kind of a v-cut dress
and it was like about you know 10% of
titty on each janna gleaming out yeah no
[ __ ] peeking out boy [ __ ] yeah just
glow good way on the side you know I
told my on the people dressing me I was
like I want to look like I feel like I'm
I'm peaking right now like it's kind of
downhill as a woman after like when you
start I'm 34 well it's us after this it
could be you get very angry
get alcoholic too if you want to yeah I
could I that will not happen to me I
don't think but right but I think that
as it's just like I just feel like I'm
the best I'll ever look and I just have
to embrace it and be like okay like just
seize this moment and just try to look
as hot as you can because it doesn't get
better than this so I told the women
dressing me I was like I want to look so
hot because on the first of all as a
comedian I can't dress up hot every
night it's a distraction on stage right
and it's a lot of work yeah but for the
roast you get to just go total full
celebrity glam you know so I was like
let's just do it I want every guy who's
ever hurt me to look at pictures of me
from that night and be like I [ __ ] up
yeah like that's that was my goal I was
like it was like you're me aunts a
moment yes I was like I wanted me on say
yeah I want it I really that was my goal
is like there are certain guys I had in
mind that I'm like I want them to look
at these pictures and be like can't
damnit I think I shouldn't have let that
go yeah yeah I like that like Chris
Fairbanks any you career stirrings dated
a long time ago yeah you just got a hip
replacement which is pretty cool yeah
he's not someone that I'm like look what
you missed out because he's like a nice
guy like no II to take that out oh you
don't have to take it out but he's great
there's just like you know those people
that you're just like oh yeah you idiot
but then I ended up hooking up with one
of these guys and I'm like you idiot you
get to hook up with me right now I don't
do this all the time like hook up yeah
and I just was but I was feeling so
great that night and it was such a fun
night that I was like I deserve this I
deserve to get fingered tonight and so I
I'm taking him on the bowling alley
tonight yeah break out the [ __ ]
buckets a gravel in the distance let's
[ __ ] you know let's party dude bet you
no fire rice ready fire away
that's awesome and so you met a man that
was this a celebrity no he's a guy that
I had built some rapport with like I I'm
never a girl that's just like that guy
tonight never met him get over here he's
a guy that I had been chatting with we
had made out once before but he had kind
of been avoiding like he's he would like
to say I want to take you out on his
eight and then never asked him just like
the classic I've done that before you
like I want to hang out
you just never do is we all three years
I have done this thing I used to do this
thing for years where I would just be
texting girls for years we're gonna meet
up years dude every other day and then
finally that went away because they
learned that you're full of [ __ ] and
then they just we would both entertain
it though we both entertained this crazy
just delusional wheel yeah they were
actually gonna hang out yeah that was
what was going on where was I I started
to realize none of these plans were
coming to fruition and so I just was
like okay I'll just have fun with this
and then we started there was some
sexting going on so that in in and then
I realized oh I don't take this person
seriously as like a boyfriend right
prospect which then frees yourself up as
a woman to be like okay I can just like
hook up with this guy and I don't care
if he calls me the next day because I
don't really want him to because I don't
trust him to be there from he can't even
get one date on the books yet alone be
my boyfriend yeah this guy's not gonna
be able to handle the whole child on the
books yes so well I don't want a kid but
like even just yeah puppies and I can be
with her and handle a shared Bichon look
yes this guy is I don't want to say
worthless but it felt that way like I
like when a guy proves himself to be so
disappointing across the board but in a
kind way yeah
where you go okay I can hook up with you
and then and feel nothing afterwards or
at least think I will feel nothing
sometimes your body does things when
you're having sex that you don't want to
happen like as a woman when a man is
inside you like chemical stuff happens
yeah yeah that so that's why I avoid sex
cuz I'm sober and like when you have
sober when I was drunk I could have sex
and not retain feelings cuz I didn't
remember the sex I was having but now
I'm sober and I'm like it's connected
there's a lot of chemistry going on in
your body that you could not like this
person then have sex with them and you
go oh I'm suddenly thinking about him
and it's not even your you don't even
mentally like him it's like your body
thinks that you're having a baby with
them now because you're right sex with
them and you're and you know I think
when a woman is is 30 you know that they
start to you guys start to get that you
know that leaky faucet syndrome where
they always want a plumber to be around
you know we're like you know what I'm
saying the faucets always asking for a
plumber
oh my boss it is
constantly Alika I am always like I yeah
I'm I need to get banged out so bad I'm
like a woman in my prime where I was
like baby having prime is what I mean
like everything in me is like have a
baby procreate
get dicks and you make children I guess
somebody just threw some come off a
building you would [ __ ] just try to
kiss my my body would just do it
I would just lay on the sidewalk without
even thinking but I don't but the thing
is so but I'm not having sex cuz I don't
the last thing I need right now in my
life is to like someone who is going to
cause me pain and be like did he text me
did he watch my insta story is he
thinking about me I just don't I'm too
busy to worry about a guy right now so I
don't want so I don't have sex so I
don't get attached right but I will [ __ ]
a guy after the Bruce Willis roaster
when you're in control in a cure [ __ ]
me on it's a night well I was
considering [ __ ] him here's the thing
I was like I could always be convinced
if you get me juiced up enough right are
we good or not Ian
everything's good okay cool if you get
me like turned on enough sexist because
every guy is heard I'm not sleeping with
you tonight I just want you to know like
I'll go home with you but we're not
having sex and then you have sex because
you can not that you've coerced that
girl but like she got turned on enough
that she's like I want a dick in me like
we have like what does it feel like does
it feel like a little itch does it feel
like somebody kind of like you know you
ever feel like okay let me take this
right so if somebody taps you on the
shoulder yeah is that what it feels like
but in your [ __ ]
no that's like so far from what it feels
like um you know talking about though
like like no like if somebody taps on
this order means they want you know like
what is it going on over here
oh I see what you mean like if there's
just stuff going on but it's not
insertion you're like no like the
feeling that you want a dick inside of
you you know okay that you want the you
know that you want that now so I'm
trying to I'm trying to get I'm not
trying to get cuz like I'm researching
if there's any links out there that are
watching this chick is a lot of you know
gay dudes or low-key DM and me all the
time I start to realize what how gross
it must be for chicks and times is the
amount of gay
mutt that I get sent all the time wow
it's a dude it's it's on its it's [ __ ]
up yeah it's [ __ ] up bro I talked to
some guys sent me like a little kitchen
cup full of like see he said it's semen
you know and I'm like what is this [ __ ]
you know no way yeah
like is this legal and me that I don't
know but that's true it's like I I talk
so openly about this stuff that there's
always guys sliding into my dams being
like I live in Tampa but if you're ever
here I would love to throw some dick
your weight like it's just this
aggressive I'm talking honestly about it
but is it black guys no no it's like
kind of overweight white guys oh is it
white guys oh I'm like oh that you think
you think that I'm going to slide it
it's just so bizarre to me that but they
shoot their shot like I I I give them
credit for that but I think I'm doing
something wrong in the sense that I'm I
talk so openly about like yeah I need to
get a good [ __ ] like that is
something that I would like to achieve
before the end of the year cuz it's been
so long yeah but that doesn't mean that
I want you sliding into my DMS being
like I would love to put my dick that's
not how that's gonna happen for me I
know that I'm very open but don't come
at me like that I'm a lady in the
streets but a freak on the podcast yeah
so don't in a freak on the stage the way
I talk on stage and then guys are like
I'd [ __ ] you in the ass I'm like excuse
me and they're like what you were just
and like mixed messages I get it but
like come on man yeah and you can't a
girl yeah and it's also it's hard to
[ __ ] somebody in the ass on a stage to a
bit but what I'm saying is this do you
think the feeling you get in your vagina
that like I need to get a dick in me is
it the same type of feet is it is it's
not you know when somebody taps you on
the shoulder you're like Oh somebody's
there yeah is it that is it feel like
somebody's tapping on the shoulder but
in your vagina I think it's like I would
more compare it to a good meal like you
like have like all the four players like
appetizers and then you're like and
maybe before you have the appetizers you
don't even want the meal you're like I
don't even know if I'm in the mood for
that right even though it's let that's
what's coming and then there's something
about the appetizers that make you go
like no I actually really want that
and I need that and but the thing is
sometimes the appetizers are so bad and
the thing is they could be good I can oh
if I'm in a position to get naked with
you and start hooking up and have you
like have your fingers and me you could
get your dick in me if you do a good job
at that other stuff that is on the table
for sure I can always be convinced right
um so then what are the what are some of
the moves that a man needs to get to at
this point so just you don't hire will
lay in there just want me so bad and
tell me how bad you want me and where we
at a motel or we had a hotel we had
somebody's apartment hotel like the last
hookup I had was at my in my hotel room
I was instantly completely naked he left
on every piece of clothing cuz I was
like you're not allowed to take your
dick out yet like you haven't gotten me
into a place that I want to even see it
right like and then I was just kind of
yelling at him being like okay tell me
I'm hot tell me how much you want to
[ __ ] me like I was I was having to like
Dracula instructor because I was like I
wanna I wanna be in a place where I
could have sex right now that would be
great he took his dick out and I go I
and I acknowledge it I feel like that
would feel great inside me I can't wait
till I saw what it's like so and so is
in the room yeah I was like that like
you recognize that the dick is there cuz
all of a sudden I looked out and I was
like it's your dick how does that come
out that is a trick that isn't part - Oh
slick yeah his dick was it's like them I
mean maybe it wasn't because there was
nowhere near right but but I saw it and
I go when did that up and I was kind of
laughing and I go I need you to put that
away because it's not it's you haven't
you don't deserve that yet and the guy
was he's I'm so attracted to him he's a
great kisser
so hot um I don't take him seriously as
it like a boyfriend type so I felt like
safe being like this is just a hookup so
it could have happened but I think he
was tired I was tired yeah and to be
honest I just don't think he was that
into me because I was telling him like
tell me how tell me when we were just at
the party and how hot I looked and how
much you like that's that's how my [ __ ]
balloons you know yeah tell me good like
I think girls just want to feel like so
desired like I saw you across the room
and you were the like we want that
fairytale
so just like lie to us and say that
that's the case because there's nothing
hotter than and I'm a narcissist because
I'm a comedian so I like when a guy is
like I wanted you we're gonna say Brian
yes yeah wild stuff now can a guy be
wild like that
yes yes I'm like so into weird stuff and
like I said like I like anal sex I'm not
gonna I know do that on I do that with
like boyfriends or some people I trust
but like I'm into some people you trust
boy like guys I don't go away and like
it's a very intimate thing to be to have
anal sex like it's not something like
sex is it's just
yeah but sex something is definite like
a next level you know just like when
you're doing it you're like you're in my
head like this is insane what are we
doing right now like is it going to Mars
kind of it really is like I recommend it
because it is just so you like what I
remember like with my ex-boyfriend when
we did it quite often but like not like
every time but like special occasions or
whatever like what's a special occasion
you mean like springtime or like kind of
like lunar eclipse because there's a
lunar eclipse actually tonight and I'm
not trying to put it on the table but
I'm just saying that like when would you
do it was it a seasonal thing it was
like usually it's the thing about anal
sex is like you have to prepare for it
wisely
and a lot of times it would be spur the
moment where it would just be like this
is some [ __ ] up sex we're having where
it's like really like dirty and he's
like your dumb [ __ ] and I'm like I am a
dumb [ __ ] like that kind of stuff yeah
like I didn't do well on my test yes
like I love that I don't want that kind
of sex every time times I want loving
sex or whatever but let me touch that
dirty [ __ ] like that let me put a snake
in your [ __ ] yeah that's weird
but early yeah I know what you're saying
I like yeah let me yeah like the capers
in your ass that just just just weird
like I think so I can sir your question
I think it was probably once a quarter I
would have anal sex okay onesie Porter's
are quite right yeah and um and
sometimes we would like plan for it but
the thing is like here's what here's how
it would go down if I thought I was
if we were having the type of sex that
I'm like oh he and he would kind of
threaten he be like I'm gonna I'm gonna
go down yes why don't I get it and I'd
be like if I was like you shouldn't do
that I'd be like might cuz cuz I always
would go No
you know like that's always kind of the
dynamic of oh yeah I'm scared but then
you really want it you know right so he
knew the difference between lake not a
good day for that right not a good time
or like let's risk it you know like you
just like check in with yourself and you
go one of me okay let's do it
and then so that was always it was it
would always be spur the moment what's
more I would really like be like you
can't write you don't understand we
don't want that happening right now but
yeah like I like I like some weird stuff
like I'm all the porn I watches all that
girls being like I like to be tied up I
like I like toys a lot of it was Home
Depot bad girls I feel like yeah I like
that stuff it doesn't need to be every
time but yeah I really like I like to be
like I think that I'm soaking in control
of my own life and I'm such a control
freak and then you need to have somebody
to really take control in those
situation yeah tie me up so I don't have
any control like uh-oh guess I don't get
to make a decision it's such a blessing
to have no decisions to be made and I
just get things done to me yeah thank
you but now I have this feeling I've
always had this long had this feeling
that a lot of women want to be murdered
you know do you ever like because women
love those types of murder shows it's
all about murder me murder me murder me
I was just like thinking this other day
of being like having a great murder
story like having you be like this maybe
a podcast comes out about me getting
murdered
and they're like it's like an eight
series or an eighth episode podcast like
on seer like serial season 3 is about me
like that's the new fairytale for a
woman like my princess story yeah it's
like to get I think you're right there's
some glorification and like like you get
murdered but your [ __ ] lives to see
another day okay I'm into that I don't
know how that would help my [ __ ] is
like a soul that would just find another
yeah like an avatar it would be like
every like kind of like it definitely
you'd have to have some unique directors
but yeah why is it I think there's
something about if you told a like I
feel like there's a lot of women out
there and I'm not saying I'm doing
anything like this I'm starting a new
small business or anything but that you
could sneak up on him and be like I love
you and I'm going to kill you I remember
it would be like this is he's put on my
nice shoes first
one time my ex-boyfriend and he is would
be okay with me saying this because it
really happened and he was so sweet
after it but it was one of the first
times we were getting because you don't
just I didn't know I was into that kind
of stuff like because I know be a laptop
choked or called a dumb [ __ ] and the
thing is being called a dumb [ __ ] I'm I
like it cuz I know I'm not like right
and smart yeah I'm a [ __ ] but I give
you a [ __ ] but it's fun to be a [ __ ]
cuz it's like there's something
empowering about it like I'm like I am a
[ __ ] like I you just feel like a bad
little girl like it's yeah it's like
Halloween for your regular self yes it's
a Halloween for your emotions and I
think that it in my essence like I could
have been I admire porn stars and like
sometimes I'm like I want to like see
what it would feel like to be one like I
watch a lot of porn and I'm like I think
these women are some of them I think
there's a types of porn that's like
really bad for women and then there's
types where the woman's really empowered
even if she's tied up and being like no
I think that she has a lot of agency in
that I look at porn stars and I kind of
look up to them cuz they do something I
could never do I could never do that but
I admire it because I think it's almost
like female stand-ups it's like yeah
you're really exposing yourself up there
strippers I feel the same way where I'm
like wow I watch them and I'm like I
could never do that and I know that
people watch me and go I could never do
what she does and people go I can't
believe that you talked about your
vagina and your sex life so openly and
I'm like that was nothing compared to
you know some porn stars who I'm like
I've seen the inside of their [ __ ]
yeah like that is that's showing
yourself that to me is like really
revealing so I admire porn stars in a
way and and like to feel like one in my
own life yeah well I've always felt I've
always felt synonymous with that I've
talked to you know some friends behind
their porn stars and and I'll have that
conversation with them they're like well
why don't you why do you like why do you
relate to porn stores you feel like you
commute I'm like because there's just
something bizarre that like you put
yourself out there and like you put
yourself like if it the hot like
physically I don't feel that comfortable
put myself out there like I'll put
myself out there emotionally and like
you know verbally and stuff like that
but but I feel like what you do is the
same thing it's just almost kind of the
other half of it or it's just a
different expression of it yes so no I'm
just a porn star you know just with my
words and feelings you know I you know
I'm just taking it in the in the
feelings but yeah I'm doing some
hardcore
and like I feel like if if you flipped
it and I what kind of porn star would I
be it would be some weird [ __ ] because
of oh yeah the way but you're right we
do oh you're [ __ ] up we bare our souls
on stage and we are like spill all this
[ __ ] everywhere we're into some scat
stuff like I'm like well I'm in like I
really like are you the female Jim
Norton that's I'm starting to wonder no
no no I'm talking about like my color
yes the words ice yes if you were to
take my ax and daughter with a big
guttural yeah it can be like really like
I can feel like afterwards spent in a
way that a girl after a really heavy
gangbang shoot run a porn set like
that's how that's how much I give
sometimes of myself where I'm like hmm
did I feel good about that
oh well it's already out there and
someone probably benefited from me
spilling all that like right now I'm
like why am I talking about this hookup
I had less than two weeks ago I don't
even talk to the guy he'll maybe hear
this all I'm having all these thoughts
of like regrets about saying this but
then I go if someone's watching who had
a weird hookup and has any kind of
Solace from the fact that I also feel
this way then good then it's fine yeah
glad I did it yeah and look it's I mean
I think yeah even just a second ago when
you said like yeah it's like um you know
the feeling after you gets another you
hooked up with somebody like did you
know did too did not do too much and too
much happened like was it - we was or
something yeah well but it is what it is
yeah I mean if nobody was actually
physically hurt and if you know you can
still talk to the person you can always
say to him like hey was that weird or
I'm sorry about this or whatever you
know it was can I tell you about how
this hookup ended up and I want you to
tell me what you think so so where I
left it
it was a hotel first of all which put
you out of my [ __ ] dating class I
like a motel you don't I'm saying I like
thin windows I'm talking about I like it
when a truck goes by you [ __ ] know
what type of truck it was just from the
[ __ ] Morse code of that window rattle
you know that you know I like that thing
I like a couple of [ __ ] flies in the
room you know you come in already have
roommates you just don't know where they
are you know what I'm saying
I like that [ __ ] this dirty [ __ ]
so anyhow so you said hotel you're with
them and you're back in the room yes so
there so we we literally are we're both
we both live in New York City but we
were in LA for so that's kind of fun the
roast and we both were staying at the
same hotel which I knew which was an
agent right no okay no but he is someone
that I had made out with one time before
we text a lot we sacks tea and sent me
like kind of maybe a dick pic sort of
thing like in his pants like bro
revealed dick but like it was like on
you know right
and um and at one point in our like in
the early stages I was like maybe he
could be my boyfriend someday and then I
quickly learned like no this is just
gonna be a fun hookup at some point and
then this night comes around and I mean
everything's lined up yeah I feel hot I
look great I had a great night I taped
the roast of Bruce Willis I had a great
set I was like feeling like belle of the
ball doesn't and I'm at the after-party
and I see him and he's like talking to
some dudes and I just like was annoying
cuz I was like why is he not talking to
me we have rapport like we're staying at
the same hotel what is how like come on
come on yeah are you gonna if you do is
walk across the hall at if you play a
couple of [ __ ] cards right yeah and I
was talking to this woman who was just
sitting next to me and I was just
opening up to her and I'm like God I was
pissed off of that I go I am the belle
of this ball and she's like you are you
just like she was at the roast she was
like and I go and I can't get laid I was
like I would have sex with that guy
right there but he's put in zero effort
and like he doesn't like he knows that
he could so I was like and she goes if
you can't get laid no one can I go I
know tonight is my night like I should
be able to this is so frustrating and
then as I'm talking to her I'm getting
worked into a lather and I just I'm like
I make eye contact with a guy and I go
wow come here
here laying the plain baby you don't
know say it park that yeah yeah he comes
over and I go what are you doing and
he's like I don't know and I'm like I
talk to me like let's bit let's get this
going cuz it's getting late 11:15 people
are like the party's winding up yeah and
so he sits down and then and I'm a
little frustrated with him and then I am
and then he just wins me over because
he's so funny and he looks he was
peeking that night too and I was just
like he's so hot I'm so into this I'm
definitely no cologne I don't know he
smelled good
he's just so hot like I just couldn't
stop telling him like you look so hot
really I was just projecting cuz I
wanted him to say the same thing what
she did but right but he really did look
good and I was like I just decided I was
like yep this is gonna happen like God
okay he did enough work by coming here
and sitting next to me making me laugh
enough being adorable she eating while
he was sitting there or not no he was
like very focused on me good to like
entertain me and he was making me laugh
so hard that I was like this done deal
yeah so then he's like I'm gonna go back
to the hotel and I'm like yeah I'll go
to so I leave and and then we we realize
we're in the adjoining hotel rooms like
they're right next to each other on the
same floor in a way so we're walking
down the hallway and I'm like what's
gonna happen here my room was like a
mess and I knew it and so I was like
let's go to your room and he's like I
have a friend staying with me I'm like
what are you doing why didn't you
arrange you knew I was here you knew
this is a possibility why do you have a
guy sleeping in your room I was just
annoyed I go okay he's not a homosexual
man this guy no you just like had a
buddy crash he's like a nice guy that's
like oh yeah my bud you got to grow out
of that
I know so this is why I don't how old is
it got 22 no he's thirty thirties okay
yeah adult yeah it's something like that
and then so I go okay let's just go to
my room it's a mess
and I'll just explain what's lying
around you know when you walk in you go
okay that's there because I'm not gross
like that was right it was there's
toilet people on the ground but it was
toilet paper that they put in between my
toes when they gave me a manicure so it
just looked like a loose toilet paper
but I was like that was from a manicure
or a pedicure and and then I realized
after he left that my vibrator was just
like out on the floor just loose it was
in passing visual we think that that is
one of those hair curler things great
okay good good it looks a little really
tight curls yeah we can just say that
she uses a really small it was it's it's
I have the thing that I use which I
recommend a builder women are watching
there is a a sex toy called the
womanizer this is the worst name but it
sucks on your clitoris whoa whoa whoa
whoa you know put it in you it just you
put it over your [ __ ] and it has like a
little like hole and yes that's it you
put the RT ball huh you put that little
opening over your [ __ ] that's it that's
exactly what I have but it's blue and
then you press the top button and it
starts sucking and then you press the
bottom button to like up the suction and
it's if you've never squirted before
which I hadn't get one of these and you
will oh my not every time but it's this
thing is a game changer and it's taught
me that if I ever eat Lizzie yes where
you can at least Gleek I bet out of a
job oh dude yeah exactly that is how far
the key can't water a plan or anything
kidding no I'm the times that I've
squirted like I've squirted twice it was
more of like a spill
yeah like it's just all of a sudden
you're like oh what the hell oh wow the
government's gonna have to clean this up
you know
a lot of [ __ ] people are gonna fight
and fill out insurance would call FEMA
like how much like enough to like dampen
a small burger like enough to ruin a
slope that is exactly the right amount I
would say half a juice box for me oh
yeah which is enough to dampen a burger
for sure about it Nick these keep
popping it's not your fault but you're
not hearing it it might just be the
headphones yeah yeah I'm not hearing ok
good as long as it's not peaking in that
um yeah man
I got some the squirting thing is like
it's a you know it's a I'm trying to
liken it to something it's like
it's just wild man it's a wat like I
like this one girl I knew like she's
there was so much squirting sometimes
like I would like check to see if she
was okay like it was like I was like it
was almost biblical you know a couple of
chapters up and it was just like this is
you know I felt bad like the cat would
come around because he thought I'd cut
the faucet off like this kind of like
dude and you had to change all the [ __ ]
like a certain point like sorry if your
squirter and you know that you are quick
put a towel down yeah it's like having
period sex like plan you know what's
gonna happen I will say that sometimes
girls squirt and they're like I didn't
what is it like the first time and then
don't don't make them feel bad about
that but a girl should not ruin your
mattress yes like the last time I
squirted what's the second time I've
ever squirted which I'm in five years of
my life what from the first time in the
second time I didn't see it coming right
like I wasn't like I'm gonna squirt
right now and then all of a sudden I was
like I would have not picked a different
position on my bed I would have put down
a towel like right it's a nuisance
because then there's a wet spot but yeah
so that thing was laying out back to the
hookup situation so that things laying
out that little [ __ ] allergen as an
ulterior motive dude well this this
device has taught me that if I ever um
eat [ __ ] which I don't like I don't I
think I probably will in my life yeah
you're about probably six months away
from it I see right now I am yeah okay
so this is what I've learned is that you
don't like licking is fine but like you
gotta suck that click that's what
brothers do and a lot of black dudes get
down there and they'll they're doing it
right oh yeah another do latch onto that
thing like a barnacle
literally don't let go they watch Sunday
oh I swear to god it is that is that's
the game-changing move I would never
have known it had I not gotten this
device and I have a vagina I would have
never known like suck on your clip that
seems weird but it's not while it's I'm
telling you the next time you go down on
a girl suck her [ __ ] and like you will
get orgasms out of her that she didn't
even know she just sucked
rectly on earth full suck don't hear
time not the whole time but like just
here's the thing and this is gonna get
kind of gross but we're already there
and it's not even gross this is biology
we keep it yeah let's make it so it
doesn't get to grow no I know woman's
clitoris is our penises that aren't
fully formed so when you're in in utero
or whatever you're trying to form dude
one girl I remember from wrestling down
here exactly I mean this thing was
really sometimes girls have huge clothes
oh and to against this thing when I was
trying to touch this lady's been chewed
this clitoris definitely seemed like if
I can could have worn you know part of a
mitten this thing was gonna rhyme they
you know yeah because she probably has
more testosterone yes no she's title
nine definitely you know yeah that
[ __ ] title not and per se you know
what I'm saying
but yes so my the whole theory is I'm
gonna learn this so your dance so so
clips are just dicks right like a little
bitty dicks that are in hiding yeah so
treat her [ __ ] like you would a tiny
tiny penis if you would if you had a
tiny penis how you would want a girl to
suck your dick so that is that is
exactly that's it Wow so that should
change everyone's style if you're not
already doing something like that like
you really need to focus on suction as
opposed to licking and whatever that is
and I'm a girl that requires a lot of
pressure down there like anytime a guy
has ever like fingered me like outside
my like I'm always like you need to go
harder you need to go hard like I can't
I mean it's like deep within
yeah and I've had guys be like does that
hurt and I'm like I can't even feel it I
can't even feel it guy and then this
this device was recommended to me by a
doctor that I talked to on my show I had
a show about sex and I was telling her I
it takes so much pressure for me to have
an orgasm and she was like you need the
womanizer Wow and and now and this was
the toy so hmm that was laying out was
it made in China do you know what
countries playing maybe Honduras a lot
of these a lot of the real good ones are
made in I'm really yeah what's and you
kind of want that I think it's Lady you
want something from [ __ ] South
America I know I do
I want to go down there and there's that
Chinese thing I'll just beat the hell
out of your vagine oh I got to oh yeah
but I want
one that malfunctions and like doesn't
let me have a choice because that's my
problem with masturbation theater is
that I like to be dominated and be like
oh you think like cuz whenever I am
masturbate I always get to a point that
it's like it feels great but then it
almost starts to feel like you're you
know when someone tickles you and you're
like oh this is fun and then you're like
no no but that's like if they keep
tickling you it like you might die your
heart might stop yeah but it's also very
exciting I always feel like when I'm
about to have an orgasm it's always
almost like that feeling of like no stop
stop themselves up like it's too much
feeling and when I'm masturbating I can
just stop because I'm in control and I
need sometimes to persevere past that to
have an organ yeah so I feel like my
problem with masturbation is that I'll
give up too soon because I'm like it's a
little bit uncomfortable and I feel like
it's too much I don't want to come and
then I I have control and so then it's
not as fun and that's that's been my so
I would love a device to malfunction and
be like [ __ ] you don't have a choice
right
we're latching on yeah you want a device
to [ __ ] show up and not pay your
mortgage and just [ __ ] you against the
wall yes you can't even see then you're
blind just wandering around no mortgage
it's all room with my wife yeah but you
are dealt but you have been dealt with
yes excuse me there I know you're
enjoying that Nikki Glaser episode she
really talks about some wild stuff but
I'm just using some of that old money
sea salt spray in my hair and that is
from beardbrand beer brand is a premium
men's grooming company and they're based
out of Austin Texas and Texas is one of
the big 50 and their mission is to
foster confidence through grooming and
they like to say over at beer brand keep
on growing now what I use also a my
beard actually my little goatee are good
is that that temple smoke and temple
smoke is this kind of is this uh it's
like a skin conditioner or a hair
conditioner you can use it on a tattoo
you can use it on excessively dry skin
it's just like this it's this beautiful
little salve that just helps you as a
man just kind of take care of yourself
beer brain is much more than products
it's education it's inspiration and it's
community so head over to beardbrand com
slash Theo and get a free sample of that
sea salt spray now we can just really
get your hair feeling nice and fancy and
also not nice and fancy and just kind of
wild as if the beach itself took care of
your hair today go to beardbrand comm
slash Theo I support their products man
I'm using them and I love them and and
you can to free sea salt spray check it
out and now back to the Nikki Glaser
episode um so you got the man tell us
what happened with this man Jesus Christ
so then we get in my hotel room we start
making out I I get naked almost in slate
cuz I just have a dress on like that's
all so it just comes off right away he
has on his full outfit he takes out his
dick I say put that away like we're not
dealing with that right now
yeah put that away dude I literally said
put it away and he was like laughing we
were both like laughing and I was just
like I'm it's beautiful it looks great
I'm sure I didn't feel great but it did
it look cool or not I kind of glanced at
it just like a cursory glance but he had
sent a picture before of it in his pants
and I was like okay that's that's good
and it in its pants the klu klux [ __ ]
who sends a [ __ ] penis in her eye and
our producer Nick just said he does that
kind of stuff yeah because it's not
terminating but it sends a message and I
totally agree with you Nick like I think
that it's a bear dick would have been
like whoa dude I'm not ready for that
but this was like oh we were just we
were - sexting he got turned on and he
just took a picture of his boner and I
saw his dumb socks in the foreground
like it or in the background like he was
just sitting there like and I just saw
like you know dude I have pictures and
I'm actually got a upset girl one time I
pictures in my dick from when I was like
young you know and so I would send those
and she was like what the [ __ ] is this I
didn't realize it it seemed like it
could be you know you know illegal or
something right and she's like what is
this and I'm like this is you notice my
dick I just I was kind of like leading
up to the my adult dick I didn't want to
sin like you know I wanted to leave a
few years bathtub as a couple decades in
between like now and then I wanted to go
somewhere too
you know hilarious he thought I was a
[ __ ] pervert and she was a creep
anyway doesn't get it that's a really
funny move
I'm [ __ ] Muppet so anyway I was fully
naked and and in that and to me and I
have don't hook up like I said this was
very exciting this is a special night
yeah I was like in the moment I was like
good job girl like you're having a
random hookup you're putting yourself
out there that's your night I'm I'm an
I'm a I'm a bold woman who just gets
what she wants and it Jessica Rabbit
yeah I felt like really empowered by it
because I've been struggling I was in a
relationship for five years and got out
of that and I've since like not hooked
up with anyone so and that's been a
really long time and almost like it's
been almost a year of just and I've
hooked up with my ex but that doesn't
really count yeah that doesn't count
that's just going no what you yeah and
so it was very exciting to me in the
moment I'm like I'm doing it I'm finally
like getting over the hump of like I can
get naked with a new guy right you know
I was like it is kind of cool yeah and
then he was um fingering me which is
like my favorite thing like I all I want
to do is get fingered like all the time
it's like so fun and sneaky you can do
it in public like it just now are you on
all fours when this happens or you'll
you're laying down on the bed on his
back and I'm straddling him and he's
from behind doing it okay you're
straddling him facing which way facing
him okay face so we're like making out
he's oh and he's around your back around
your buttocks oh wow or maybe like was
but like yeah it was like yeah it was
like that and he's doing a great job
sneak around brother [ __ ] remedial
reading yeah and I was sayin I am
getting fingered this is all I've ever
wanted like I was very in my head I was
like good like it was it was a moment
for me I was like a good job this is now
I broken the seal now I can just start
hooking up again you're moving to the
big city
and I should be hooking up I'm a woman
who like works on my appearance works on
my looks I want to [ __ ] sometimes I get
out of shower and I'm like I look so hot
and I wish I could send a picture to
someone but I have no one to send it to
and I don't want something you just want
to put somebody into your [ __ ] yeah you
just wanna like treat someone to this
thing I've worked on and I'm not gonna
have this body forever I'm gonna start
aging and it's not gonna be like I don't
feel I just feel
sexy right now and I want to be having
sex yeah and um and so I felt good and
then I just I think that and then I
started being like okay I don't know
that I'm gonna come from this because
it's I'm very complicated down there
like you have come hunter to you
somebody that's just all you trying to
come would you start going I would like
to but I just realized that I don't care
about coming I could care [ __ ] come this
year next year yeah I don't rely
honestly don't care because I think sex
feels good anyway yeah and I went so
many like I went so long in my life
without coming because I just didn't
know my body and I still am confused by
my body so if a guy is fingering me and
I'm like I'm not gonna come it's nothing
based on his performance like sometimes
I'm like I don't even know what to do
man so then I started telling him I
started telling him like okay tell me
how hot you think I am like I just was
like I need to feel more desired in this
moment what did he say like on a scale
of 1 to 10 that's so funny he's like
you're like a comedy 9 oh my god ok I'll
take it
no he he he he told me the things I
needed to hear and I'm like tell me um
how bad you want to [ __ ] me because he
what he was trying to [ __ ] me and he was
like I want to so bad and I'm like
that's kind of a cheesy answer though
that's like the easiest thing hey I want
to [ __ ] you so big he was tired and it
wasn't he just I don't think he was that
into it and that's fine because as soon
so got to a point I was like you about
as much as I want to sleep right now so
and I understand that right don't take
offense that there was a long [ __ ]
night we were both working like [ __ ] you
yes so I want to fall asleep really hard
in your [ __ ] yes sometimes I would I
love to like sometimes just like lay
back and just like kind of sleep as the
guys [ __ ] me oh yeah I like that
I would totally enjoy that but we're not
there and I didn't want to sleep with
this guy yet because of the feelings I
get when someone's inside me I was like
wasn't ruling it out I always couldn't
be convinced yeah but then he took his
dick out again and he goes come on and I
was like where would we even get a
condom he's like well there's the
pleasure packs cuz we were staying at a
hotel with like you know the sex kit or
whatever and I'm like it's back to a
motel all of a sudden you know like this
not the thing on the wall we put the
money in no this one it like you know it
was at the W hotels there's like
Pringles in there so it's like hey you
want these Pringles or you wanna [ __ ]
yes so does that
middle ground they're so weird that
they're right next to each like at least
throw something built duds and you know
something in between [ __ ] sex and
carbs brother you know so funny
so he goes yeah there's a condom and
then I was like okay so that's nice to
know that there's one in the room if I
decide to have sex with you but then it
we just I would say another minute and
you go condom every time you're always
condom and if I'm not in a relationship
no no I don't wanna kind of yeah they're
not great I think I've even heard
someone say the word confidence tupid
also they should put that on the package
that they're [ __ ] dumb they're stupid
but they're and they're not even cool
when they don't even really feel like
sex
I just don't know somebody's [ __ ]
somebody's you know angry at you and
it's just yeah is it from somebody that
you're trying to [ __ ] at the same time
so then I totally agree with you like
condom sex I'm just like yeah it's not
even good for me like cuz I know it's
not as good for you so it's not as good
for me I'd rather just get to a point
where I trust you enough and we're like
and you get tested and I get tested and
we can just like start finally I think
about Christianity that Isle of Man is a
Christianity's like no condoms [ __ ]
get in there you know yeah in a weird
way they have a point people are like
it's just about birth it's just about
you gotta have a baby do they also enjoy
the feeling of [ __ ] sex really so they
wrote it into the document that's you
know buddy so so then a minute I would
say this hookup and all like it was
probably seven minutes long Jesus I've
been about an hour and 15 minutes on
here I know really sorry it's good now
y'all have this so then I get to a point
where I'm like it's this I'm not gonna
[ __ ] him cuz he's just not getting me to
the point where I want to get [ __ ] I
keep having to wake him up to move his
fingers around and this is if this is
not a slight against this guy like he
was so like I just was tired too and so
I got to the point where I just go I
really wish I had in my vibrator because
and that wasn't an insult that was like
with you fingering me plus a vibrator
like that would have been I could be
everywhere like it would have been
amazing a sauna by you all of a sudden
but with the womanizer it's a it's a
it's not the same as a vibrator like you
need it that's more of an alone tool
whereas a vibrator you can incorporate
fingers and dicks right have to do it so
I go I wish I my vibrator and he goes do
you just want to go to our separate
rooms and jerk off and I was like yes
Wow and I climbed off him he stood up he
didn't have to put on any clothes
because he was still wearing everything
yeah and he goes you were seriously so
great tonight
this was fun and I was like this was so
fun he leaned down we kissed again and
then he just went to it he walked out
went to his I heard him in the next room
like getting ready for bed and then I
just cracked open those Pringles
wouldn't hear her to cut the biggest
fart right he wouldn't that have been
crazy that would have been almost
awesome but it sounds no it sounds like
it you heard him crack the Pringles no I
cracked the Pringle oh that's awesome
I just stood in my bed and watched like
the end my feelings challenges on
Instagram and then ate Pringles and was
like it got to the point where I was
like oh my god I just had a hookup like
that was so weird
and it was so diplomatic and sweet and
it felt really good it felt because I
was scared that post hookup no matter if
I had sex or not that I would feel some
kind of longing like I hope he texts me
or or what is he gonna say about this
but I felt none of that and it felt just
like a victory and then um and then and
and and since then I've been like oh
does he even want to hook up again like
I'd be open to it but I was like based
on that experience I don't think he'll
like be interested again but yeah I
think so he is interested yeah I think
there's something you know what you know
it really made me interested at the very
end was when there was something kind of
there's something nice about the
earnestness of like you just want to go
to our rooms and do this own thing and
you agreeing to that I think it puts
suddenly it puts for a guy it puts
everything into like uh-oh
this doesn't have to be some weird thing
we have to play like a game this this is
a this is an OK space where I can just
be honest about what I'm thinking or
feeling and I can get you know and that
woman's gonna reciprocate she's that
Nikki's gonna feel that same way and is
gonna respect that we really were like
on the same page and I think the feeling
I had afterwards that I was that you're
kind of suggesting that I related to in
the past in my 20s given the same
circumstance I would have blown him I
would have [ __ ] him I would have done
something because I'm like this guy
it's too common and I don't make him
come he's gonna hate me there was always
that kind of thing oh yeah so I think in
the past I would have just gone out of
my way to make him feel good about it
and I didn't need to do that because he
did feel good about it and we both left
feeling fine about it and now there's
some like anticipation of like well what
could this be
we didn't we didn't we didn't do any
crazy oral nothing now it could be
anything could happen I've only seen
yeah if there was a cursory look at the
dick it was very [ __ ] you know
Sherlock Holmes really when I was 28
even maybe 32 I'm 34 not two years ago I
would have been sucking his dick and
hating it oh yeah and I don't want to do
that to myself anymore and I refused to
like if I don't want a penis in my mouth
it's not going in amen I have a whole
life I know you have and that dude so I
can relate to that like I really get it
especially with all these dicks coming
into my [ __ ] bro you can this is the
first time I like even like this is what
it's like to be a chick you know
constant people emailing you you know
small buckets a calm and just I'm gonna
get this I'm gonna get so much I don't
want it [ __ ] sent out probably a
couple of ounces do premature Nick I
know he was a premature baby but he's an
adult okay so he's a and that's good my
pics are like job references available
upon request you never you never
initiate yeah I just think as a woman
when you're in my 20s and early 30s even
like just until recently I just thought
that you have to make a guy come and if
you don't you're a bad woman and it's a
bad experience for him and he'll never
call you again
the truth of the matter is if you do
make him [ __ ] he probably won't call you
again because you've given him what he
wants and he's already had that and now
there's no reason to see you again and I
don't even like comin what's the time so
if somebody makes me come sometimes I'll
leave upset see oh okay I've been with a
guy like you who just doesn't want to
come and I've talked to my therapist
about it they say it is um well they
said with the guy that cuz I used to
date this guy who just would be like no
no I don't want you and I'm like you're
almost going to I want you to and he's
like no no no
no later let's save it for later like
what is going on here save it for
Christmas or save it for like a party
and later would never come is the thing
like he wasn't saving it for later we
never would finish I'm like how did you
just go though like edging it is edging
but here's what I think and I like
edging - I'm cool that's saving up that
bus I love being like that's revving the
[ __ ] camp before you set that [ __ ]
loose at the [ __ ] and you know at the at
the land of pines campground yeah for a
better orgasm when you stave it on I
love porn where the guys like you're not
allowed to come in the girls like please
can I please he's like no and I'm like
that I mean that to me like I'm getting
turned on thinking but I love what I
guys like you're not allowed to it she's
like but I need to like I'm going to and
he's like don't do it and I love that I
haven't seen that but I'm definitely the
best so then but I think this this my
therapist told me that this guy didn't
when he comes for a girl it means to him
that he now owes her something like he's
which you know biologically I think that
like I got a surrounded rate with the
baby with the girl there's something in
you that's like I will then have to be
accountable and oh this girl is that
severe commitment issues that's it you
feel like in so did this guy you feel
like when a woman when when a woman has
made you come there's something there's
a release there there's you're out of
control in that moment this woman has
just now controlled you in a way and now
you feel out of control you feel like
you now owe her something because you've
come and and biologically if back in the
cavemen days you would have owed her
something you would have helped raise
that baby that you just made you have to
go hunt for her there's an expectation
there that I think is still ingrained in
us deep in our [ __ ] brains that well a
biological you mean there's a biological
thing inside of us find that if we come
that if we ejaculate that that then a
child is being created something's being
created so there's this thing where if
you do that in a context where that's
not happening as a man that some of us
at a certain some of us could feel you
know could still be really like rooted
into that biology where we feel then
like that
that we're gonna owe something to that
woman that there's going to be a
responsibility there with that woman
yeah yeah that's funny I never thought
about that but I definitely can really
really relate to that I would not want
to come I even in college I'm right hook
up with my girlfriend and I would not I
just would not want to god never really
liked now I'm a little bit more relaxed
about it but I used to be extremely
uptight about it man let me just say
that as a woman um we really I like when
a guy comes like I like come in sex like
I like that there's like a thing at the
end and that no that part and weird
yester yeah do some freaky [ __ ] it's
like when people come out it's like when
people like you know it's like when
somebody orders the fajitas at a Mexican
restaurant everybody's just like having
regular food and then somebody comes
about with that [ __ ] smoky dish and
you're like damn that's it yeah and
you're like I should have gotten that
yeah that's fun and and that's the way I
felt I was always like I like I like the
finale and I understand not wanting to
and I want to respect any guy who
doesn't want to but I feel like um it
does take away from it work on letting
that go because it just feels incomplete
it feels like you just didn't like
you're waiting on the check and you're
like okay we're ready to go
yeah and then somebody just comes up and
you're like oh you can leave there's no
check and it always felt frustrating to
me and maybe women who have hooked up
with you and had this experience feel
the same way it's like cuz I know you're
going you want to you're turned on by me
everything's leading to that I don't
feel like I'm not pretty enough that you
didn't come like right there's no
circumstances where the guy like loses
his erection and girls can convince
themselves like he doesn't like me which
is not the case at all twenties but no
that's not the case but in this case
you're like hard and about two and
you're like no no no no Ryan and so I
walk away with my my self-esteem
preserve because I'm like I know he was
there but then you're also like confused
like why not yeah what's going on I
think we hit on that funny I'd never
ever really been able to kind of figure
out maybe what some of that could even
be you know well thanks for sharing that
you are like that because I think that I
don't think that many men would admit to
that but I think many men do exactly
that like I think it's a very common
thing yeah well I think there's some
psyche huh I think if at the very least
I think there's you know it can it can
help me in at some of the psychology of
why some of those behaviors are that way
because if for a long time in college
and stuff I used to think or in my
twenties even I would think that it was
because because I used to be like really
in like going to the gym and stuff I
used to think oh well there's part of me
that's like oh and you would feel weaker
if you like if you had sex and then went
to the gym you'd be like [ __ ] man if you
got off went to the gym I'd feel weaker
you know because you are you're
physically are weak they're like you
know you're ready to rest like there's
things that happen in your body
biologically that kind of you know tone
you down it sound like I want to be
amped up I don't want to bust over here
because I'm have to do you know triceps
enter now when it's you're not gonna be
as much fun that's a really good point
you're right like after you come you're
just like yeah all and you're at you're
spent yeah and I think I was so anxious
to and like so defensive and always
thought that people were against me like
my back was against the wall so like
well dude you can't [ __ ] cuz then if
somebody attacks you or something you're
gonna be what way more likely to not we
look weak yeah so I think yeah I think I
had both of those syndromes and we
events it makes total sense wow that's
crazy man yeah and I feel bad you know
if you know if some of my ex-girlfriends
because they would have some of you know
I know that they you know sometimes it
would make them feel like something's
wrong with them you know it makes me
feel kind of sad a little bit but
because they should have yeah but they
didn't know why would they think I call
this guy doesn't want to bust out you
know yeah what did you say to them in
those moments what would be your
reasoning like I don't want to come cuz
obviously they can tell you're almost
there I'd say I'm saving up for
something and it was the worst excuse
ever saving up fern-like them well that
was the thing I didn't get specific and
that's where it made it uncomfortable
ice thing to hear like this is this load
is for another lady
why would I would just say it's I'm
saving up for something you know I'd
leave it kind of right it's filling up a
couple later and take a picture and send
it to a guy this before people are doing
that [ __ ] and I've never done anything
like that now I don't do that kind of
[ __ ] yeah but yeah just say I'm saving
up for something you know like uh yeah I
don't know could be if I'm going hiking
or something maybe this we're gonna get
stuck in a half a lie it's a-you know I
don't know I would just kind of leave
would you say that I'm saving my
strength like it is my like I don't want
to be depleted of energy or would you
for something okay that is so big and
the girl should have followed up with
what does that mean yeah I'm sure they
did yeah and then
I don't know we should get out of here
something like that you know some type
of [ __ ] we shouldn't be here right
now and like we're in your apartment
it's like yeah but have you had
girlfriends you never know yeah I've had
some girlfriends man yeah what's been
your longest relationship maybe three
years
oh that's long okay oh well I haven't
been that good at it you know like you
know I've had definitely like I mean I'm
getting better now but I've definitely
had like a lot of like just sexual
inadequacy issues over the years you
know but one thing you're saying is you
were talking about what do you mean by
that
I think now that I get older I realize a
lot of it was I even got to the point
where I didn't want to have sex with a
woman because or I would get disengaged
pretty quickly because I didn't want
that commitment yeah like I just didn't
you would like lose your boner for the
girl because you were scared I was so
like it just and not like yeah I was and
so then it would get to the point though
I find that I would start having to
watch wild or sexual stuff online in
order to you know to mask that or to get
my excitement up you know and so that
like became this and I'm still kind of
that's where I'm at now it's like I'm
real I know that and so I have to I have
to see like okay well there's some stuff
here if I want to be in a successful
relationship I want to be in a
comfortable comfortable physical
environment or emotional environment
that I'm gonna have to actually do some
work on some of those areas and some of
it I don't want to do the work on I
don't either
Theo I'm so on board with it like it's
the the porn I watch is disgusting and
it's like that's a dark arts and we
talked about it on the air a lot of
times Nick is a victim he's you know
he's probably definitely look like he's
watched some [ __ ] stuff I mean the
stuff that that you know where they go
this you this is a suggested video for
you like I'm starting to see blood in
those videos where I'm like no I don't
want that and they're like we'll see you
next week and only you're probably right
like you know weird like they just know
where you're going cuz this it's a
slippery slope if you showed me the porn
that I'm watching now you hear it it's
okay if you start to see plasma in those
videos and that's really bad and I'm
just checking blood I don't watch out
that no it it wasn't blood but it's like
you know like fake it it looks like
blood but it's candle wax or something
but I'm just like I don't even
even into the idea of the imagery of
like thinking it like you're getting
into that Transylvania [ __ ] yeah but I
mean but if you literally if you showed
me the porn that I'm watching today a
year ago I would have been like oh god
no I don't want that but like you just
get desensitized and then you need the
next thing and and so I've been trying
I'm guessing you're doing the same thing
as take a step back and trying to get
back to your roots of like yeah just two
people [ __ ] and not having like weird
stuff happening or like stepbrother
dynamics or whatever the [ __ ] thing
is that you feel weird about that
brother Dexter any step family turns me
so hot you know hot um you know you know
that's my read taboo from the step
family belt you know I mean you
definitely somebody better be a cousin
in the house and nobody's [ __ ] but I
relate to you saying that like cuz I'm I
am reaching an age where I'm like oh I
want a partner I want I see my friends
getting married and I'm like oh that
seems nice and I've never thought of
myself as someone who would get married
like I just don't like putting a title
on it and I think it puts too much
pressure and I just think that most
marriages fail because they do and I
just um I'm okay with being with someone
and being like let's just see how far we
can take this and have fun together do
you ever feel like the desire to have
somebody and you like at a certain point
that that is some type of man like it's
that you want a child and it's just some
and I'm not saying this in a messed-up
way you know but that like that is part
of that feeling you know and I don't
want a kid like I don't want kids I
really know that about my fear that from
you I feel like you'd be a great mom
here's the thing is like I always and I
don't feel like a lot of women would and
I feel like we need good moms out thank
you like some of our strongest women are
getting into this other thing where it's
not where they don't want to be moms and
that scares me sometimes but I would be
a great mom I know that and Schumer has
a joke where she's like people are
always like I'd be you'd be a great mom
she's like yeah I'd be a great
prostitute to but I'm not doing that so
that's the way I feels like there's a
lot of things I'd be good at but I'm
have a motherhood as a magic trick that
you can do that somebody that I can't
you know yeah I you're so insightful
like I met a guy that I was like I think
that sometimes you just meet someone you
fall in love and you're like we need to
make a child together like I could see
that I don't have anyone that I want to
make a kid with and I think then so it's
easier for me to be like I don't want
kids but if I met someone then like dude
I want to like mess our DNA up and make
something like I feel like that just I
could be convinced just like having sex
I can always be convinced yeah but right
now I feel like no I'm good
because if like your sexual feats are
getting wild enough where eventually one
of them might be like hey I can make a
child pop out of your vagina and you'd
be like oh this sounds like a video ad
what you know I think that that's really
hot is like I've talked to some
girlfriends who have like had sex where
they're like put a baby in me and the
guy is like so turned on by it and she's
turned on by and she's like why did I
just say that but like it's like there's
something so hot about that yeah that
baby comes out with a whip god [ __ ]
he climbs out listening to crazy music
just moving his [ __ ] shoulders you
know it's my baby he's not crying dude
and he's listening to Marilyn Manson
spike collar yeah beautiful paper with a
beautiful bow what is that I think to
find someone that you want to make a
baby with and you want to like be like
to have a real intimate good
relationship you I'm not in the place
for it yet I really ever feel like
because I I you know in this and already
okay but do you ever feel like sometimes
that if you did have a child like it
would go against some of the vibe that
you've created in your work life it
would be it would just be so much work I
would have to I want to be rich enough
that I would be able to hire nannies and
help like I because I can't have my
career and also raise a child it would
both would suffer so I would need things
in place we thought you'd a lien a
denier audience though no no it would
only like I'm just no it's a I don't
think that I'm like this like voice of a
single woman that's like we don't need
to have kids and I think what I am is
the voice just whatever's going on I'm
just honest about so I think people
would go with me on it so you don't feel
like your life that feminists like
man-hater type of voice know I love men
yeah I like and I'm
I feel very yeah I love men and I wish I
didn't so much and I wish I wasn't as
distracted as I am by guys that I've
crushes on who I only choose because I
know they can never truly be there for
me because I'm scared of intimacy so I
picked guys who I know will never love
me and I want them to love me so bad and
but I'm doing I'm picking them because
they can right Wow so I'm in control and
I don't even realize it because if I
really wanted someone who is gonna be
the husband that I see for myself
someday that guy is out there those guys
are interested there they're chatting me
up but it it does it kind of repulses me
right now to have a guy be like I see
you and I want to support you and be
there for you it's like it scares me
right now so then no I want to hear more
about this because I think I think this
is like this I can totally relate to
this why does it repulse us like why
does it scare us why what is we don't
love ourselves yet fully like we haven't
really fully accepted ourselves and
because I love myself a lot more than I
did at any point in my life right now
I've worked on myself so hard to have
good self-esteem but it's still not
where it needs to be where I I don't
love myself to let someone else love me
and you can't if you don't love yourself
no one else will love you so it's
literally impossible to find someone to
love you if you don't already love
yourself I truly believe that so I'm I'm
50% there but I'm not all the way there
and so what a guy loves me I go oh
what's wrong with you you you don't
there's something wrong with you if you
love me because I'm unlovable and you
don't know that but I know that deep
down I'm unlovable so I don't trust you
now Oh cuz it's like oh you're something
yeah oh you're not able to see when
someone's a frog I want someone who
thinks they're better than me because I
think that they are better than me you
know what I mean like you I want a guy I
want to win over a guy and convince him
as opposed to just someone being like
sure yeah I think you're great I will
say that's changed a little bit like now
I love when a guy is just pursues me
hard I think that that is like a really
healthy direction my life is taken
because I used to always go after a guy
who wanted nothing to do with me and now
nothing turns me off more than a guy
being like not into me I really I want
to now I'm finding guys who are
super into me come at me hard but are
still emotionally unavailable and so I'm
still finding guys who are unavailable I
used to date guys with Persian guys yeah
I mean kind of like international
[ __ ] dudes in terment like guys who
have [ __ ] been in Dubai at some point
oh yeah definitely
guys who have girlfriends or like guys
who are in open relationships I I pursue
guys that like me and are attracted to
me and want me so hard which feels good
that I'm going after guys who actually
want me but which wasn't always the case
but and then I'm like I want them so bad
and then I realize no you don't because
you wouldn't if you loved yourself you
wouldn't want a guy who would do that
who's there's no way that he is going to
be the man for you because his life is
not in a position to be there for you he
doesn't he doesn't care about you he
doesn't love you and he can't love you
it's not within his realm of
possibilities to love you yet you still
want him to love you at that point it's
my decision in any time when I get hurt
by those men I don't get mad at them
anymore I'm like you're setting yourself
up for this neck well like I say that to
myself now because I'm like I'm choosing
these men based on the fact that they're
unavailable yeah deep doubt I know it do
you find it hard to be honest with the
guys and relationships no you don't know
I find it really really easy but you
find it so easy to the point where it's
almost an escape sometimes like it's so
easy it's like oh I'm gonna be so honest
with you right now that it's gonna put
you in a place where it's gonna make me
unable to connect yeah I think that
sometimes it scares them off a little
too soon when you're just like hey I
like you and this is where I see this
but I think you have to be honest I'm
not gonna change that because I've
played games before and I continue to
play games you know you don't reply it
back to a text right away even though I
know what I'm gonna say yeah I'll wait
on it oh yeah
make him think you know that left unread
they call it yes I leave things unread
alright so I play those kind of games
but in terms of like I recently was
dating a guy and it was getting to the
point of like okay I want this guy to be
my boyfriend oh well a guy or not not a
black guy I don't know why you keep
asking that do you think I don't see how
brave you are
I don't same brother up I would love I
would love to brother future is beige
baby brother up
well this guy I really um I I liked him
a lot and and we didn't even we just
like hung out a ton and we never kissed
or anything but it was just like it was
really cool was it a comedian yeah Marc
Norman Walker would it be the [ __ ]
woman unless she already had no I have
not you didn't ladies love that guy get
so many ladies he's really attractive
yeah he's a handsome guy
yeah and he's unassumingly attractive
like he comes off as this like I'm just
a comedian and then you go is Martin
Norman hot yeah all my girlfriends and I
are clean oh you're married to him he
has a girlfriend but like it's I will
say that if Mark is watching which I'm
sure he'll hear about this and I've had
so many discussions with girls where
it's like have you guys noticed like
mark Normand it's hot and they're like
yes and we're all like so confused by it
but I think guys that say you don't know
me like I'm drinking of a mark no he's
just you know he's just nonchalant he's
just at first he's just like ah he's so
honest but by the end of the night
you're like damn is this [ __ ] James
Dean over here yeah I I remember going
like there was a meet-up in Central Park
with a bunch of comedians years ago and
he was shirtless playing frisbee and I
was with my friend and we were like
what's good like we were both like why
is he hot all of a sudden it really
happened overnight
yeah um but no it was so anyone I was
hanging out with this guy and I realized
like I really liked him and um and I was
like kind of playing games trying to be
like I'm cool with whatever you want
this to be and then I got to the point
where I was like no I want this guy to
be my boyfriend I don't want to be just
friends or whatever we're doing right so
I told him hey listen here's where I
here's what I want with you it's not
possible
clearly because this isn't progressing
towards that and and so I'm not
interested in in anything less than that
so by well and he was like wait a second
we were supposed to work together on
this thing we were supposed to be you
were my friend like we've been friends
and I'm like I know I'll miss you but
it's not what I want and I'm always I'm
just gonna always gonna be frustrated
with you then hmm
and I don't want to you know what it's
like we'll just be friends it's like now
I just I don't want to pretend to be
friends with someone that I'm secretly
crushing lasting yeah but don't you
think though that the
or something sometimes with by by being
so empowered that you you kill some of
the room for fun yeah I and I think he
would probably say that too is like we
were having so much fun it was like a
flirtation it was it was leading towards
that and now you just were like flipped
to the end of the book and we're like
well are we gonna get to this right
you're so efficient that it's not if it
doesn't get to this then I don't want
that it is very much like line in sand
but my frustration with this guy in
particular was that it there was no I
was I was being consumed by my thoughts
by of him you know everyday oh yeah is
he gonna text me yeah is he gonna watch
my Instagram story like write healthy
and it and I'm too busy and I have a bug
in life to manage and when it be Kuenn a
guy becomes stressful and a burden it's
like get out of here I need I need to
move on from you so I'm cutting this off
because if I stay friends with you I can
convince myself like oh I can be cool
with friends it's like no I can't like
you I was gonna feel around forever yeah
there has to be a way where you're
managing your life in your emotions as
well um you know cuz yeah if you just
let it yet things can just meander
around like sheep forever you know God
the guys get stuck in that situation a
lot or they'll be like I like you too a
girl and she's like I just like you as a
friend you mean so much to me and
they're like okay I'll take it I'll be
your friend yeah and then they end up
hating that girl it just breeds
resentment and I would just rather have
no relationship than one that I'm
unsatisfied with yeah even though I miss
that person and I talk to him every day
and then I'm we just don't talk anymore
and I'm like oh that's a bummer but
that's what a breakup is yeah yeah I
mean it's tough it's tough out there I
um you want on the apps I'm not on the
apps no good for you so I uh I was yeah
cuz I've worked like sometimes I'm like
I didn't just know like I mean I know
that like a lot of women like you know
especially like the past years has like
been the big feminist movement you know
everything's so feminist you know and as
soon as I wonder you know cuz I grew up
thinking my mother was a feminist you
know like in a way my mom had four kids
you know she's a hard worker you know
delivers you know newspapers and has
always just been a delivery person right
but she's very educated she just had to
you know raise her kids you know she
graduated from Duke University
but but just had to raise her kids so it
also always makes me think like
sometimes I just worry that like you
know there's some of this does this
feminist thing where it's like but none
of these women are like moms you know
like why are these angry and they're a
lot of them start to seem angry and it's
like are you just doing all this other
stuff and it's you're missing this void
of sheer empowerment which is having a
child like that seems to me like to be
the most if I can [ __ ] make something
out of my [ __ ] dick you know I'm
saying I'm freaking you know I've been
spraying out for decades and nothing's
climbing out of the same you know here's
here's what I'll say to that and I think
you have a really good point there it's
like we can do this amazing thing that
you guys can't do and it there is an
empowerment in that and there there
could be a that is feminist to be like
this is what I want in life that I get
to make this it's my baby and I'm gonna
be a strong mom because I can and and
that's within I will say though that
it's not an accusation it's just I want
to know about this conversation because
I think a lot of women I find are
getting there's a lot of women I'm
seeing that are confused even friends of
mine like women are hitting me up that
are like in their authorities that are
like you know like I have this great job
and everything but I'm you know I don't
have any eggs frozen what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do with my life yeah you
know people hit me up for [ __ ] semen
on the DL you know I think that my
hesitation to be a mom and it's not
about like I don't want to get I
wouldn't want to be barefoot in the
kitchen but there is something to that
of like as a mom you have to breastfeed
you have to be with the child a lot more
than the dad does like it's it's I have
a huge career and you have a huge career
you know to add breastfeeding on to your
career like it's a lot to ask like it's
it would be a beautiful job but I just
don't want another part-time job and I
know I would love that job and I would
be so good at it but it's just I don't
have the energy right now and I'm open
to it in the future when my life slows
down a bit but and I think it would be
just such a gratifying experience but I
I I'm not angry as a feminist and I
here's another thing that I think you
brought you were kind of touching on is
that women are so empowered now that
it's making us less feminine
and I think I got to that point where I
was always the aggressor with men I
would always be like white like let's
kiss
let's take me out do this like I be I
wouldn't be the feminine energy and
that's what I'm really trying to do now
is like guys should come to me they
should pick the date they should call
the car they should well some of us like
pick up some flowers and look lost I you
know I used to say that sometimes like
because as a man there's just something
inside of you that like you know if a
woman's doing deadlifts like what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to know I want to be
I really am trying to because I am on
stage like again on stage I'm like very
masculine like that's a masculine energy
I mean I think allies is like super
masculine to the point where I mean
that's too much but like you are I don't
know but you do seem like a feminist but
you also seem like a relatable woman
like a woman that I can communicate with
and I done like extremely in touch with
a lot of different things so that's why
I think this is a neat conversation go
on but I think being a woman on stage
with a mic commanding a crowd is a
masculine thing to do as a woman just in
general aside from my material it's just
a masculine thing to be in command of a
room and kill right you know it's like
that's a dude thing to do so I think
that wow it is a really dude thing I
can't imagine that feeling as a woman
that it must be does it feel out does it
feel
abnormal no but here's what I'll say is
that that's guys have girls wanting to
sleep with them after shows a lot more
than girls have guys because I think it
goes back to that cavewoman stuff is
like when you see a guy on stage talking
you're like he's the tribe leader I want
to [ __ ] him I want to make babies with
him because he's he's telling us he's
telling us where to go hunt today he's
he's he's the orator he's he's the chief
guys see I want that I want that when we
go on my mother I bet yeah but they
don't see that in a woman who's who's
telling everyone where to go hunt that
day like I bet they do some of them like
that to be my mother not the mother of
my child yeah yeah it's just not it's
not um I don't do it I do a masculine
job and so I have to work on being more
feminine in my own life and that's why I
say like I'm a I'm a man on the stage
but like on the streets I'm like talk to
me like a lady Courtney yeah pursue me
buy me flowers like I'm not gonna
go like what are these [ __ ] flowers I
I'm up there can't like I'm not gonna I
don't have that energy offstage I really
want to be a girl offstage and it's it's
hard for me to mitigate those because I
do because you have to have the one on
the stage you have to be in control and
like badass and then offstage I want to
be a little bit like more yeah but it's
hard for me because I'm sometimes that
stage persona comes into my regular life
and I am like kind of ballbusting
offstage sometimes but yeah I'm trying
to really get in touch with my feminine
side more because I think that that's
what men are drawn to and I'm trying to
draw in men yeah and I think that it's
it's it's tough for me though because
I've gotten to where I am in my career
by being like I want that I'm gonna get
that very masculine thing to do and the
type of men that are drawn to masculine
women are not the type of men I'm into
so I'm putting out something that is
getting me suitors who I'm not
interested in how many students you get
to just want to be your business manager
really I could see a ton of that love
that I really like I keep thinking about
JD dude you're just thinking like yeah
assistant um there's no there's just
like a lot of because I've been talking
about this kind of thing recently on
different podcasts and stuff and I've
had a lot of guys just in the middle of
the country being like I know that I
live in Seattle but like I would be so
good to you and I think you're beautiful
and I love your thoughts on this and
they really like see me and I feel seen
by these men but they live in Seattle
I'm not gonna start a relationship with
them and also I feel like I need someone
in the biz really not not like not like
it necessarily a comedian but like first
of all someone who I need the most a
body a I need yeah like an actor but
like they have to be funny they have to
legit make me laugh Damon Wayans sure I
don't I'm not really familiar with his
work as much as I should be but yet
Damon Wayans would be fine like a
comedic actor comedian or torsa or a guy
who's like um like a slightly less
successful Paul Rudd yeah or a more
successful but Legault I'll take
any kind of level of success but I want
the guy to feel really secure about his
success like Donnie Rudd cuz I've dated
rub yeah his younger brother Donnie I
don't even know if it's a real person
but I imagine probably just doing well
in the wake of Rudd you know yeah yeah
and they got that like ageless oh yeah
DNA
I just want a guy who's like very secure
with himself and I think that that's
something in the industry that you can't
really find as easily but I'm also an
insecure person who's found a way to be
secure in this business so I think there
is that possibility but I just want
someone who isn't because I've dated
comedians before who are just there's
just an emptiness inside them that will
never be filled
yeah and I don't like that like I want
Marc Maron yeah like I think you just
and I relate to that cuz I'm a comedian
I want every stranger to love me I want
everyone to love me I'm desperate to be
loved yeah I would like though for one
person one man to love me and be like
that's enough I feel good and I feel
complete because I feel like I've tried
to love men in the past to our comedians
and they don't want my love they want
the love of the crowd and and they and I
don't want I don't want someone who is
always craving strangers I love surfers
they call them do they yeah the Kelly
Slater's of love let's go to a couple of
calls this is a great conversation I
could go there's a couple ways I wanted
to go I want to go to I wanted to talk
about orgasmic meditation because I got
into that for a while I wanted to talk
about some other things but we're gonna
have to do at a different time because
you know how to do om I was in there you
got in and I was in yeah I was in for
like six months oh dude I was I got bit
by a [ __ ] uh Bichon up in Topanga
Canyon touching some lady yeah and it
was all sanctioned this was sanctioned
you know by that Commission or whatever
this is legal have you talked about this
yeah I don't know if we talked about it
people keep asking you elaborate I think
it might be more interesting than some
of our questions if please elaborate
Theo my boyfriend my ex-boyfriend was
trained to do a limb yeah and he did it
to some strange woman okay I'll tell you
what happened so hot I know it's not hot
it's supposed to be very leg mechanical
I you know pee-wee's big adventure right
you remember that yeah the film right so
they have this lovely lady was an
actress in at name eg daily and she
played Pee Wee's girlfriend can you
bring her up do you mind
she played Pee Wee's girlfriend in the
original movie and she also was the
voice of Tommy pickles
oh my god and get it on here yeah okay
Wow there we go so eg came on my podcast
allegedly which was my original podcast
with Matt Weiss and she was awesome she
was extremely charming and we kind of
really related she's super super cool
and we related and she invited me to
this thing called orgasmic meditation ii
she spoke about it i felt just into it
you just click on just any of them
movies how many pickles one so ii she
you know i felt into it so next you know
she invites me to this place downtown
and we're in this it's like a seminar
they got coffee and you know a little
bit you know some pineapple cut some
cuts of pineapple and cuts of different
fruits you know at the front people's
milling around and doing that next thing
you know they got a lady up and they
closed the doors about 250 people in
there they have a lady at the front they
got her spread eagle you know what i'm
saying which is uh which I think should
be our national bird you know what I'm
saying boy I salute that dude I doubt
any brothers would kneel if they [ __ ]
let that thing fly across the stadium I
know that that is I hope you write that
down that's really funny well I mean
that's just what's going on yeah so
anyhow next thing you know you know
they're teaching how to diddle diddle
the lady at the front of the room right
yes and there's a doctor up there yeah
so fast-forward five hours and a lunch
break they've got us paired off
partnered off in a different twosomes
and you're just diddling whoever you're
set up with and you're fooling mean this
you have gloves on there's doctors
walking around like it's like lost it's
like one of the you know which should
have been maybe the last episode of lost
that they never put together because
dudes are [ __ ] losers who couldn't
you know who just wrote their way in a
cell in advertising but but anyhow like
they got da in your touch and a lady and
people are spraying out across the room
like you can tell who's doing good and
who's doing bad can we talk about like
it's all in her wounds but like why okay
women enjoy it why do the men enjoy
what is that relation so here's the
thing they teach you how to pleasure a
woman with your hand right the woman
gets pleasured and this goes back to
what you're talking about earlier it
feels like they don't have to give any
reciprocation because there's no
reciprocation for the man but here's
what the man gets so you there's it's a
15-minute process and it's a safe
process where a woman knows she can feel
sexual pleasure from an actual man and
that they don't have to give anything in
return so it's a complete safe space to
feel good and also there are terms that
the woman can give to the to her male
instructor that lets the man know how
they can better please the woman right
and there's specific terms that don't
make the man feel bad if he's not doing
it right
right so it's it's very calculated and
as a man here's what you get you
actually get to make a woman feel good
with a woman's permission and with a
woman's direction in a comfortable way
where you're not just guessing and
assuming and going off of things you
heard in grade school or things that
some [ __ ] you know you know idiot or
some you know older brothers friend who
now works at a [ __ ] Chevron or
something for 40 years told you and so
you actually get to make a woman feel
good and so you leave out of there bro
when you leave out of there dude you
feel like damn just you know John Wayne
Gacy or whatever who's the UM John Wayne
sorry yeah JC's of a serial killer but
you feel like you know like you have
like you know in your in your fingertips
you have the magic yeah because you got
a woman off you didn't get anything you
didn't get any you didn't bust you got
all this Chi built up so you're rolling
around town just with the magic touch
you know you got that King Midas you
know you got that clitoral King Midas
you're running around and um what are
the words can you reveal what are some
of the things that women can say to
direct you in different ways yeah higher
lower more pressure less pressure can
you go a little faster please can you go
a little slower please
to the right you know to the left now
slot you know and that was a joke I did
use one time in the thing and he got a
couple of people to laugh and one late
even farted a couple people over when I
did use that joke but so anyway so next
thing you know I'm on the floor
I'm in on the floor of a huge warehouse
in downtown Los Angeles there's about 80
people that are coupled off into groups
of 40 some people don't even get
partners they got [ __ ] sent off the
island by John sorry dude but then but
next thing you know you get to the end
you're like wow this lady came or didn't
come but still felt good what is what do
you do after she comes like do you shake
hands do you look at each other i thing
you have to like slow down it's like
kind of like a downward stroke that you
would use on the woman it was like a
downward pressure and then in the end
you use like this kind of closing press
you really put both your hands on her
vagina with like this and you like kind
of press on her for like two or three
seconds there's this whole template of
how it all goes down and I remember one
guy they had in a wheelchair he got
partnering up with a lady so this dude I
think was like his let you know in his
legs didn't me feeling his legs he got
hit by a [ __ ] car bus or something or
thrown off a horse or something but um
we had to pick him up out of a
wheelchair a horse and then got hit by a
bus it could've ended that [ __ ] HB
combo that row it's nothing after that
but the wild part was I remember lifting
him up out of the wheelchair and laying
him next to his partner so he could
still use his arm so he got it you know
he did his job and I remember we put him
back in the wheelchair he felt lighter
oh she could feel like he just felt he
got some mojo back yeah it's got to be
taken from you when you're in a
wheelchair and and and feel maybe maybe
that was like his way of yeah I mean I
think if heat is on for more ladies he
too [ __ ] waltzed out of that [ __ ]
you know but it's just crazy the
empowerment that you get by not by
making somebody else feel good and so
then next thing you know you're in the
group you meet up with once or twice a
week there's like these crazy meetups
and you're diddling whoever shows up
you're partnering up there's almost a
square dance thing in the beginning
where it's like which is it okay if we
um they call it oming orgasmic
meditation is it okay if we own together
and Nick seemed like yes so you partner
up and you know you set each other off
and you're diddling 50 60 70 year-old
women you know you literally like you
these are women that you're not like
attracted to oh no I was best looking
man and woman in the whole [ __ ] place
a lot of times but then you're on the
easy road then you're out they have an
app you're on and now you're [ __ ]
driving around telling you of a business
meeting and a half hour later here in
some apartment you're in I was in a nice
house in the hills a couple times what
is the process before and after when
you're meeting with these women what's
the conversation leaving before and
after
so everybody's on the tight timescale in
their regular lives but they want to
have this moment it's home it's a
meditation it really I literally
definitely need to do this because I
need to have orgasms that are brought on
by someone else but I don't want all the
follow-up of like Willie call me or like
do I like him or that it sounds like
it's only human I need an escort
no why not this what's what's the
difference you could do this so this is
what happens I would show up we would
have we'd have text in advance
communicate in advance okay I'll be
there 12:15 you know I'm five minutes
late no worries so we get there and the
person the woman has a nest set up and
the nest is just a way you set up
pillows and a towel so that they can lay
down so the woman can lay down the man
you roll in you got your bat you got
your little gloves you got your you know
and straight up dude I've always wanted
to be at my heart I believe a cafeteria
worker right deep inside of me there's a
[ __ ] beautiful big lady [ __ ] scoop
and cobbler you know into the plate of a
young boy who's hurting in a lot of
different ways but for a moment feel
some warmth when he sees this woman you
know and there's also like unnecessary
hair nets everywhere you know and I
[ __ ] love that and so so anyway you
know you show up you have your gloves
you have your little thing of Lube and
you know you show up and the woman takes
her pants off and you're sitting you
kind of sit cross-legged to the lady
lays down you put a leg over her body
you're facing just over time you don't
even looking at her like she doesn't you
don't make eye contact it's none of that
[ __ ] you know this ain't yeah this ain't
a family you know I love the leg over
cuz it like holds you down it's a little
bit of its secure you get onto the UH
it's like whenever you get on to the
Batman ride at [ __ ] Six Flags and
like where's the and you're like yeah
it's just a simple bar but you're like
no I feel I'm not gonna fall out yeah
I'm not gonna fall out that I make sure
I put my camera in the cubby hole for I
got on yes I did everything's secure
right so then you know you have the
woman's underpants off you have the
vagina you're kind of looking down at it
and then you just have this kind of
broke that you start to do you know
right they teach you this method yeah
and they teach you this method and the
woman knows what's going on you've
learned the method in the classroom so
now it's a real practical thing and then
it seems to be a thing that functions
constantly and that people do
nobody's raping each other there's not a
lot of that it's like a meditation that
is um apparently is respected by a lot
of people and they they used to charge
like to be in like the group there was
like a fee to learn it now do you think
they charge Wow I think it's just a you
know just a thing that's going on now
what happened to me was I got [ __ ]
attacked by a bichon I was touching this
lady up in um Topanga Canyon so that's
where I always think about getting a
lawyer and stuff and finally I'm like
man [ __ ] it man that like bit oh yeah
this thing [ __ ] bit me dog and I
respect it you know I told her to lock
the dog up that was a thing and I've
been over there a couple times and it's
hard to also fend a dog off while you're
trying to touch a woman's crotch you
know what I'm saying
but look I've had experience with that
going full circle trying to [ __ ] while
pee or throw rocks at or so it all kind
of coming back it's all a little bit
nicer do you still do this I don't do it
I would get back into it what made you
get away from it the Bashan attack yeah
yeah definitely the attack and I've
shared a room with the bhishan I've
shared a room with a child too when I
was in college not an Asian person an
actual [ __ ] animal and and so I've
been around you know some some dogs I've
been attacked by dogs I got attacked by
dogs and cats one time I birthday oh you
know I've had different experiences with
Ana you've seen a lot of vaginas through
doing this like how many girls do you
think you've owned with uh maybe thirty
okay what um what have you learned about
vaginas like cuz that's a different
that's a different thing than a hookup
cuz then a hook up a lot of times you
don't get to like really look and see
like what the mechanics are have you
learned about vaginas in a way that
maybe I don't even understand cuz I only
know mine yeah like what what are what
are you seeing out there like what do
you don't like what is what are some
recommendations if you were if you would
if you were about to go service a woman
what would you want her to do down there
check it out make sure that thing's
running top oil you know nothing wild
down there I don't want some you know
you should have got it serviced a couple
times you've been skipping out because
you you know
just make sure that your vagina is like
kind of you know you want have a clean
vagina clean yeah because there's a lot
I would say one out of seven vaginas is
not clean how could they not clean up if
they know you're coming over clean
you're just also I used to know a girl
and this is she would put a finger in a
vagina and then taste it herself to make
sure that it tasted okay yeah yeah yeah
which seems very wild to me you know
what I'm saying I mean I [ __ ] I've
slipped over to the buffet and had
something off of it before I paid for it
sure but I respected it it's like ya
know what's going on it's the same thing
like as a guy like you'll do this and
I'll be their [ __ ] and rub your hands
you know I'll probably lick myself off
your face so I'm not opposed like that
like tasting myself I think it's
actually kind of hot so like you might
as well be like okay what am I having a
good day right like what's going on yeah
you don't need to [ __ ] tell us a mint
in there yes sometimes you just need to
like do something else
but [ __ ] yeah I can't believe those
don't exist but gents I one time I had
enough ladies the gents I you and I
should definitely sell them I put a
gummy worm up my vagina once because my
or was that good that game there used to
be a game people were doing online I'm
really hiding gun where was their vagina
no way yeah it was like or know somebody
reenacted like Lord of the Flies where
they had like a cave and it look like
the gummy worms were coming up that's
funny no I did this because I was
picking up my ex-boyfriend a boyfriend
at the time an order to tell him it was
it was his favorite food was these like
gummy worms and I would always buy them
for him and I was picking about to the
airport and I knew that he would finger
me immediately when we got in the car
cuz it's my favorite thing and getting
driving while you're being fingered is
like hiding so I put one in Jersey right
before I picked him up so he gets in the
car and he's fingering me and he's like
what the [ __ ] is any pulled out a gummy
worm and it was just like a funny joke
that's awesome yeah I was I was pretty
good um no definitely and that and that
so a vigil just sold a thousand magic
kits of a gent know it seems good but
here's what I'm saying is that uh family
talking about
um you need to get back into oh yeah
like you just got it yeah it's just the
scent that was the biggest thing and
outside of that that was it
I mean this is you know I noticed this
as well like it gave me a different
respect for women because if you're like
pleasure and a woman who's 65 years old
you know it's like you start to realize
oh that like you know older women do you
know they are still women they are they
do need pleasure and they do you should
treat them like a woman like that's what
it may mean it made me realize a little
bit more like oh you know this is a
woman this is a different thing they may
not want to [ __ ] her but she's still a
woman that has sexual desires and
deserves yes and deserves like some sort
of treatment or some it just puts things
in a different it puts things in a
different frame than our society puts
things in and I think that's that became
one of my Knock sometimes there's so
much attack like on men the way men are
but really a lot of it is the way that
advertising is the way that the society
is especially Hollywood the way that
[ __ ] industry is you know it's
talking [ __ ] hole and it's not it you
know it tells you at one moment you you
got to be good to women you got to do
this in that but then it's but you know
but then it's selling you know the dark
arts out of the other hand you know it's
telling women love yourself for your
body body acceptance but also like fit
in these jeans I mean they're just mixed
messages constantly but I really love
what you're saying about like older
women are still like sexual being oh
yeah because I remember one of the most
depressing moments and it's still like
haunts me because I know it's like going
to be in my future but I remember I was
in high school and one of my best
friend's moms would always be like you
girls are so young and beautiful she
would always kind of like talk about
that and I remember one time she just
was standing there and she goes I
remember the last day a man held the
door for me mm-hmm and then she walked
out of the room and I was just like oh
dear there's a last day for that we're
like you are attractive to men and men
go out of their way to be maybe the door
to his apartment I think maybe but I
think a lot of men where I'm from it's
scary to be like like oh like your water
was sitting there earlier and I was like
well I don't know usually I would like
open the water just and then leave it
open you know just so that you know you
don't have to open the water you know
and I was like I don't know if I if I do
that you know she might get upset if I
do that so I like that that would have
been like Oh
God what like there sometimes guys are
courteous in ways that I'm like it's so
nice like it just doesn't happen as much
anymore I don't think guys hold doors
for good
well I think in LA and in the cities it
doesn't happens much which is crazy it's
like this a lot of the cities I feel
like a place where it's supposed to be
so you know we're all about each other
and like you know we're you know we're
respecting the opposite sex but then I
find that traditionally ways aren't in
some traditional ways like I'll hold
that I would help a woman with her
luggage like these days you don't know
if a lady's gonna get [ __ ] pissed you
know
I think err on the side of doing it
because I love those moments where I'm
like oh my god like a guy took care of
me I don't wanna carry luggage I'm an
independent woman and I kill on stage
and I have all these like I know what I
want but I'm still like not as strong as
you yeah and I don't like dealing with
heavy luggage and I like doors to be
open for me and I like water bottles
like I like that [ __ ] still so I think
maybe some girls might be like I got it
but I think let's all go back a little
couple steps and and and I know what
this hold me to movement everyone's
scared of doing anything that makes
women feel marginalized or lesser then
but I think
let's keep children chivalry alive I
like I like that you do that I think
it's important because if you don't have
that if you don't have if we're not
honoring like what some of the
biological desires are of things and it
seems bizarre like here's the thing like
if a woman puts an ad like puts a sexy
picture up it makes me want to have sex
there's nothing I can do about that it's
inside of my body I don't [ __ ]
control it you know and then if you act
sexually at all now there are things of
course that are over the line but if you
act sexually then you're a [ __ ] creep
or a pervert you know can I show my body
without you can but there's there's
repercussions that live inside of me
that I can't [ __ ] control like what
do you want me to do like some woman got
mad at me on airplane cuz I had an
erection in my sleep you know wait a
second yeah it was just older kind of
Jewett I think like Jewish kind of like
New Jersey lady and she [ __ ] and her
husband you know and like he didn't say
anything I'm like [ __ ] Speak Up do it
on an erection in my sleep she
complained maybe get a made him bring me
a blanket on the airplane
oh no Theo that's so big
I'm sorry oh I was pissed and she's like
uh you know she's like you need to learn
Oh your body sir your body and I'm like
this erection ain't for you you [ __ ]
Muppet you know tell your [ __ ] man to
beef you down right there you know till
[ __ ] silent Mikey over here [ __ ]
silent you know whatever his name is
Yahveh lor whatever this dude's name is
tell them to [ __ ] beef you down you
know that's erection aim for you I made
this thing in my sleep that's crazy that
that happened but I guess that happens
all the time it just made me mad
well it just made me feel like I can't
be I can't if I can't be biologically
then I can't even be yeah um so that's
where I feel like there's just not a
voice sometimes cuz you there's been
this thing you can't say anything no you
can still say stuff and got you're still
saying stuff who's supporting any of
these you like you can't say anything
well I'm the one that's spreading a
message of like tell me I'm hot like if
I put out a picture where I look hot I
want to be told I'm hot yeah like that's
at least me I don't know I I feel like I
allowed of guys are responding this
whole thing of like I'm not gonna say
anything and I'm like well I don't
really want to hear from you anyway so
that's fine we'll never really like into
your compliments about my looks
anyway but you know there there's still
a time in a place for it and you're like
women that are putting out sexy pictures
they do want to be seen we still want to
be seen sexually yeah I'm not saying all
of them but I think that I think you're
you're not wrong to respond the way you
want to respond like it makes you want
to [ __ ] I'm sorry that's just the way I
am I can't not be yeah we want to be
able to be okay to [ __ ] but we also
don't I think it I think a lot of
everything that's happening right now
things great you know we just have to
keep testing the waters we learn the
yeah make mistakes you're gonna make
mistakes that's not to say go try to
have sex with someone and try to rape a
girl and be like I was just making a
mistake but you know yeah we needed some
calibration look America needs a ton of
[ __ ] calibration yeah we're way with
and it's great I think everything is
hand right now is great because we need
things were wave there was a lot there
was a lot of false stuff going on
everywhere and it's all I think I'll
we're seeing a lot of that now like
and we're having to ask ourselves who
are we you know we're having to ask
ourselves am i racist am i sexist do I
think about these things do I not think
about these things how do I behave
towards my child or my mother and my
daughter you know like Who am I like so
and I think stuff like that's good but
we could get into a lot more I want to
get into a couple of calls real quick
because we have to honor these because
people will send them in and we'll move
pretty quick on him Nick if you don't
mind
hey Theo this is a match from Pittsburgh
it's party for Mickey I just listened to
your mom's house podcasted she was
talking about how Dane Cook inspired her
to cut off her labia kind of to save up
to cut off a baby but she realized that
was a bad idea but she said Dan reached
out to her and said something but he
never got around to what what he said
was born with her she could talk about
that
thanks man good work Dane reached out so
the story is that I didn't know that my
vagina would be any different than any
other vagina until like I heard Dane
Cook do a bit about like girls sometimes
you go down on them and it's like
getting lost in the stage curtains of
your high school and then the whole
crowd like really laughed at that and I
just was like wait is that if I have
some extra stuff down there am i weird
and then you look at porn and you're
like oh all vaginas in porn are just
like there's just a line there's nothing
else like they're very tidy and I was
like well I don't like that exactly and
so I was his joke was the first thing
that set me off on a path of like hating
my vagina and mingling any guy who sees
is gonna like throw up on me and leave
me yeah and so and this was before I had
sex or had ever been commenting they
call it and that happens sometimes
my buddy Matt actually went on a date I
think with Anne Hathaway and almost
vomited really because he was homosexual
he didn't know it oh well that makes
more sense now so I I wrote and I
eventually got to a place where I like
got a I hooked up with guys even though
I was scared that they were gonna think
my vagina was not ideal hmm and then I
found out like my vagina's [ __ ] great
and I've never had a complaint if
anything it's like one
oh it's an amaz pig it definitely is and
but I hated it for so long because and
it all started with Dane Cook's joke who
I was a huge Dane Cook fan still think
that the harmful to it was the harmful
swallow album I think this actually on
retaliation was this joke but I just
remember being like his joke was the
first thing that made me realize my
vagina might not be ideal to men and
that they might be making fun of it
behind my back which is the biggest that
was my biggest theory if i hook up with
a guy and then he's joking about me with
his friends and saying I'm gross down
there like that's horrifying so what
happened so I wrote an article for Cosmo
about how I used to hate my vagina and
then I learned to love it in it I said
that I felt victimized by Dane Cook's
joke which was the wrong choice of words
because I wasn't victimized by but I
just felt really like it it was it led
me down a path of self-hatred his joke
and that was my choice to go down that
path he was making a joke
it killed it's still a great joke I
actually love that joke he I wanted to
have him on my shows doing a show about
sex at the time not safe on Comedy
Central and I wanted to have him on to
talk about that joke and specifically
and be like hey have you changed the way
you feel about vaginas do you still
don't like vaginas like that like what
what's and I wanted to tell him my story
I called him to ask him to be on the
show I had never called him before
because I think our people reached out
and he was like I'm not interested right
let me give him a call and he goes I
really didn't like your article and I
didn't like that you said I victimised
understand that make me feel upset and I
said I totally hear that and I'm I
apologize for that and that was poor
writing on my end like I completely
owned it because it was it was just like
I just didn't have a better vocabulary
when I wrote that and I should have been
more thoughtful and obviously you didn't
mean to hurt my feelings or hurt me or
hurt women and it's just a joke and and
I'm sorry for making you feel like I
called you a someone who would victimize
someone yeah and um and he like we had a
great talk and we were talking about
dogs and we just left like and he was
like yeah I'd be open to the show and
then we just never really followed up
but he was it was a just a great talk
and I just I have no problem apologizing
when I made mistakes and they had
written that a year before it was a
fresh mistake I'm still making mistakes
choose words wrong I've regret things I
say I have no problem being like no that
was shitty and it was shitty for me to
say that about his joke and to call him
out like that yeah and so he accepted my
apology and now we're great okay there
you go
let's hit another one here hasty on
Nikki this is DJ I'm from Kansas City
big fans above you guys I got a little
quick little three-parter question for
Nikki you talk about banging comedians
all the time my first question is would
you [ __ ] CEO no my second question is
what position would you [ __ ] vom and
then my third because I know you love
anal with you let's see oh [ __ ] you me
ask why thanks guys and I didn't feel a
thing
I didn't pre uh no of course none of
these okay um what I [ __ ] Theo it's not
off the table because you're I feel like
there's always um we're adults so it's
legal it's legal
um but I so I think any like I could
[ __ ] anyone so that's an insult to you
or a compliment to you it's not gonna be
alive you're um you're an attractive man
who's funny who I mean all the things
that I described before you're kind of
like I'm sure people were like well what
about those two Gooding together but I
think I probably wouldn't have sex with
you because of the things you've told me
about like just based on I think in the
future I could we could have sex and
that would be like a thing that could
happen but not anytime soon because all
both in the same position right now of
like no right that's a good point
actually like oh he's like oh I'm just
[ __ ] about problems right right
exactly like you're we're very similar
so yeah like oh look I'm the one with
the problems in this you know I think
that's I think that um yes so I maybe
would and then um what position like I
said I'm a bottom so I probably demand
that like I'm kind of a bottom sometimes
too just depends on what time of day it
is really so we'd probably do more of a
side thing where we could both be
bottoms you know where you're just like
let's just like be on our sides and just
that kind of thing and this watch TV and
then anal ed I only do that with
boyfriend so then that would
to be so it has to be some long-term
long-term stuff yeah yeah well we'll see
how it shakes out all right next one do
we have anything else a CEO sir Jamal
Patrick from Tacoma wash hey Jim I had a
question for Dickie
so I guess here it goes Mickey on a
scale of 1 to 10 how Joe Dirt is Theo
von
I just like to hear your thoughts on
that um that's about it I don't really I
am I saw that movie once but it's been
so long that I retained no information
about it yeah it's a good movie I
thought it was a documentary when I
first saw it so I would say 10 okay then
there's like a pet rock in it yeah he's
got a couple of different you got rocks
thrown at you okay I get that I get the
hair and everything is kind of checking
out there but um no a lot of stuff is
not checking out though also a ton of
stuff we have different faces and he has
a [ __ ] horrible hair look at that
[ __ ] it's ironed on the back [ __ ] Kim
and I would never iron my [ __ ] hair
do when I pressure wash it for the
holidays yes
let's go one word all right this is the
last one and I just got to apologize for
the listeners that either playing some
manners yeah that's a question for Nicki
my name is Justin I'm from the
Pittsburgh area you know I was just
curious I mean you see you look like
you're a pretty classy lady maybe I
don't know you all that well or in all
but never let a guy each but out here I
get classy enough lady maybe you're in
the just figure than that
have a good night guys have a good night
is he a [ __ ] security guard who else
walking says have a good night [ __ ]
as he district water on the corner of
building with a [ __ ] flat so funny oh
my god okay what um yeah I mean yeah I'm
into some weird stuff like
it's not that wouldn't be a requirement
I've never had it happen oh wait no I
think I've had like a tongue there yeah
I think where it's been like whoa and
yeah I like anal sex oh I like I like
butt stuff so yeah yeah I would I would
let and they'll bet is that some of them
that's after a shower right intense
shower like oh yeah like cleaning it in
a way that's like yeah power washing
yeah like yeah I would never lick my leg
that's yeah you can't be having some
liquor dirty but it's disgusting and I
don't know people it's totally dangerous
people get sick from eating ass all the
time people are doing it a friend of
mine did he went to n Burr and he came
back with like a [ __ ] his whole
throat closed up yeah cuz he had a
couple of them while he was over there
some guys [ __ ] loved it and they
don't they just they want it and there's
no prep going into it they didn't get in
there and it's and that's part of it
they want it to be dirty yeah it's so
[ __ ] disgusting what they're doing
and they just feel like dirty little
boys and they love it but like our
guards I wouldn't I would be very
uncomfortable if I was not fully cleaned
and someone went back there I would just
I wouldn't be able to enjoy it cuz I'm
like he's eating whatever's yeah
whatever's already been eaten yeah a
second and eating
so let's um what else we have oh wow do
you want to give you a gift oh really
and from our sponsors some of them
anyway we have Ridge wallet that is a
nice wallet you can use it's a front
pocket wallet what really yeah that's
pretty cool
yes I love this color so it's for like
credit cards and stuff like that it's
also a kid double as a clutch I guess if
you go out I need one of these I was
just about in the market for a new
wallet oh and it's like one of those
little toys you get as a kid where you
like do yeah check him out yeah just the
cards slip right in and so it's just if
you're just going out you're just taking
that then it's perfect you think about
that for a lady this is the greatest
gift ever I love knowing psyched thank
you bet and this is from Allah Lakeside
maple this is just like some fancy Oh
vegan you are right up my ass what's
vegan - yeah that's gluten free ginger
chai I know
delish come on lakeside maple guys thank
you
they'll love that and uh yeah
so man this was such a great
conversation I feel like I feel like we
really
I feel like this was like therapy yeah
me too no you have anything a look at me
to think about some of those reasons why
it cuz I've never even thought about
that as the reason why I didn't want to
ejaculate that I was like you know I'm
such a commitment issue such a folk I
think you're gonna get a lot of feedback
from men who do the same thing or like
holy [ __ ] that's why yeah yeah yes tough
I mean it's tough being alive sometimes
isn't it it's that's our new podcast
it's tough being alive it's so tough
being alive vo it's a constant struggle
dude somebody emailed me recently and
they sent an email and they're like
they're like you know one way maybe to
think about life is that you're this
energy that's just out in the galaxy and
then actually being forever for attorney
and then life is just this one moment
where you get to kind of get to come up
to this glass and just kind of see the
other energies and then you [ __ ] just
go away that's the way I think it is
it's crazy I think that we're just like
this is like one part of our the whole
thing yeah and it's a fun part but it's
a lot of suffering yeah life is
suffering life is suffering dude
somebody said that as someone said it
and they're they're dead on it is
there's moments of like intense joy but
it is it is hard to be a person really
old I'm trying to figure it out yeah
well we're hot on the trails of figuring
it out Nikki Glaser thank you so much
and we will do an advertisement at the
beginning so people know about your
podcast
yeah um you up right yeah you up is the
radio show it's a Sirius XM radio show
every morning Monday through Thursday
from 7:00 to 9:00 a.m.
west coast 10:00 to 12:00 East Coast and
then we also do a podcast called the you
up podcast that you is just highlights
from the radio show yeah I want to come
and do the show whenever I'm in New York
oh you have to you're you're can I just
say for a second like you are my
favorite comedian right now like it's
I've been getting this question recently
like who's your favorite you always get
it as a comedian when you do interviews
who's your favorite comedian who's and
right now I'm like Theo von Rachel
Feinstein like you guys are the only
people I want to watch on stage right
now you're just doing Theo you're doing
something so different you inspire me to
be like think outside the box and like
because you're so vulnerable up there
and you
all the stuff that I'm doing which is
like be honest and say what's really
going on but you have this other side to
it that it's watching you is like so fun
and I don't even enjoy watching stand up
anymore
you've brought watching stand up as a
you brought that back into my life
little sis watching you and I'm so glad
for all your success because you deserve
it you're truly one of the funniest
people working today and I'm so excited
for where your career goes and isn't
weird well we'll always know each other
I know like we're not going anywhere
like this is our rest of our lives I'll
like go to your funeral or you'll go to
mine I mean I don't mean to be sad about
that but like that's true I hope you can
make it if you just like not go to Grand
Rapids that weekend would you cancel a
gig dr. grambs will understand can I
send in a video
honestly I'm debts I don't care no I
think you're hilarious as well yeah in
constantly getting funnier and uh and
it's very speedy to say I'm happy to
even just be able to sit in a room with
you and talk this is really cool
so fun I sought out this podcast because
your Instagram videos they make me laugh
out loud it's so hard to laugh out loud
nowadays like it's always just you just
see something go huh but like literally
like crying tears in bed watching your
videos and I'm going back so far I went
back far enough where like you weren't
doing those videos I was like where did
they start like I went you know my kid
did and it's all good it's all funny
like I I don't know what you you fit you
figured it out man and I'm excited about
it well that's well Nick Davis and my
producer helps me so much and and you
have a lovely producer too that I met a
very pretty young lady yeah Noah no whoa
no Abby or is my producer she looks like
Lady Gaga she is she is the best thing
that ever happened to me
yeah she is she runs she produces my
show it's producers are great yeah well
your show is great a lot of women love
it I know I have a friend who's a
comedian named [ __ ] I hate it one of
this happens yeah Carla yes sir yes been
on the show but she's a friend of the
show and yes she loved you
she loves that show she's a real girl
she's she's rad she's someone who
I met she's a comedian but like she was
a fan of mine yeah and like heard me on
every podcast was she saying so when we
met she just knew all of my stories I
knew all the guys I've dated and and so
all I had to do was learn about her and
then we were boom friends it was sewn
I'm often friends with fans because I
relate to that being because there are
certain celebrity girls that I see that
I'm like we would be friends right
yeah and and then you get to meet him in
some times you would be yeah yes
phrasing it's interesting
well um yeah we'd love to have you back
again and thank you so much thank you
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]